Film Courage: Erica, take us back to your moving
to Los Angeles and I believe you booked your first
TV show just two weeks after moving to LA? Erica
Wernick, Personal Coach, Author and Speaker: Yes,
so I get obsessive about my goals and my
dreams obsessive I think it's a good thing
although it can border on unhealthy and I knew
that I wanted to work in television (I wanted
to work in Hollywood) and so before I moved to
LA about six months prior I started researching
people to connect with and I emailed about 150
people cold email. I would watch the credits after
a movie I would look on IMDB for tv shows that I
enjoyed and look up people who were doing what I
wanted to do which at the time was graphic design
and I would cold email and message people and so
that is really what helped me book my first tv
show so quickly because one of the contacts and
now granted out of 150 maybe three people you know
wrote me back or were helpful so it wasn't a lot
of people but one of those contacts ended up being
very helpful actually maybe two but one person
really connected with me and it helped that he was
a little younger he was closer to my age and so we
sort of connected as friends and that really
helped and i always tell people you know when
you're trying to make connections in
this industry work on making friends
you know really try to think about it as you're
connecting with people that you can genuinely
connect with because those are the people that
are going to be so much more open to helping you
so that's what happened so i i connected
with this one guy and he was very nice and
i came out to la two weeks two weeks
a month maybe before i was gonna move
to look for apartments and i ended up showing him
my portfolio so that he could kind of you know
get an idea of my work and then when i moved to la
the very first week he gave me a test like a test
project to see how i do under pressure and you
know if i can do this you know designing graphics
for television not that it really requires super
different skills than designing graphics for
anything else but the pace is different and you
know they're going to be looking for something
specific so um he gave me a test he actually did
pay me for it which was really sweet so it was
on a show that he was working on and he gave me
one of the graphics and said here make this logo
um and i guess i passed the test because the
next show that he was offered he couldn't take
and so he recommended me and then i got to
interview for that show and and then i booked it
when you went back after looking for the apartment
and you i'm assuming you flew back was there any
doubt that maybe you wouldn't come out or you were
ready to go no it's so interesting to look back
at that time because i look back and i think like
why weren't you more scared or why why didn't you
have more doc i was so obsessed i had done in high
school i had done a summer at ucla and i did their
intensive theater program and so i had already
spent some time living in los angeles and i
was enamored with it i just thought la was
glamorous and you know everything that the
movies make la out to be i joke about it because
at ucla we weren't really allowed outside of the
ucla radius on our own so i was like la is so
beautiful it's like well westwood yes erica
did you see hollywood or downtown
um but um yeah i just i was so
my heart was pulled to this city it you know
i just knew that i needed to be here so no and
and actually when i was supposed to move to la the
week before i developed a disease in my eye and i
still have it to this day and my parents were like
maybe you should push off your move like a month
or so let's get this figured out and i said no i
need to be out there now i started building these
contacts they know that i'm coming in a month no i
will get an eye doctor out in la and that's that's
what i did so i was determined and not only
that but it was 2008 yes so the economy was
unraveling yes things were turbulent yes i didn't
really feel the effects of that until 2009 because
i moved towards the end of 2008 and booked that
first show so quickly and then this first show
we did a season and then it was canceled
and so after that show was cancelled and
then i was unemployed it was almost like because
i booked that show so quickly i didn't have time
to be super confused and alone in la yet
because i had worked so quickly and then
um after that show was canceled and the
economy was crashing and it was incredibly
difficult it was the worst year of my life
i mean i really struggled right and i know
i think you've talked about that in your book
and we're hoping to maybe cover that i just want
to go back to one quick thing and i think that
is is is that something you expected to to book
a show so fast or because you had the one contact
who seemed dependable you you felt that was
something that was definitely going to
happen i mean is that normal to get something
i mean i don't think i had any expectations
in terms of time i will say you know that's
something because i was so uh passionate about
my dreams of working in television i never
considered a time frame i never said i need to
make this happen in six months or i need to make
this happen in five years you know a lot of people
uh give themselves a deadline and in my mind i
never did so i never had any timeline expectations
um i was just so excited to be in la i mean i was
also terrified once i got here and i didn't really
know people here so i was very alone i mean it was
it was a pretty challenging time and i was
absolutely terrified in the beginning but
i was i just knew that i was excited
i knew i wanted to be here so
i didn't really have any expectations
of when or how it was gonna happen
what if it's been five or ten years and someone's
not any closer to their quote unquote dream and
they come here from somewhere else i think that
question has nuance because i've worked with a lot
of people who have been here for five or ten years
who feel nowhere near their dreams and who are
really struggling but if we're really honest it's
not like absolutely nothing has happened in five
or ten years so maybe they're not where they want
to be yet they haven't booked that big tv show
yet if they're an actor or you know they haven't
booked that big project whatever their craft is
um but it's very i don't think i've ever met
any artist out here who literally has not done a
single thing in their career in five or ten years
unless they got a day job that became their sole
you know priority and then they just worked on
let me get a promotion at my day job let me try
to move up here and and that becomes the priority
so the only time i've ever seen like literally
nothing happen is when the day job becomes the
priority over the dream and they kind of let the
dream go for all those years but of my clients
that i've worked with i think it's important
to celebrate what you have achieved
and to take like even if you're not
where you want to be and it's been years
take a look at what you've actually done
even if it feels small to you because i think that
um if you can start shifting your focus onto what
you have done instead of what you haven't it'll
help you feel more confident it'll help you feel
you know just better energy you'll feel proud
of yourself you'll feel better and so i think
that will lead to more things happening um now
that being said you know when i work with people
there's so many things that we can take a look
at like you know why are you not where you want
to be yet and so we can take a look at what are
the strategies that you either haven't tried at
all or that you have been procrastinating
you know that's a big thing um or that
there's so many pieces sorry i feel like this is
gonna be a long answer but there's so many pieces
to it it's like with the strategy piece it's like
are there things that you haven't tried and then
if there are let's take a look at why right
and that all comes down to your belief system
the fears that you have the doubts that you
have whether or not you believe in yourself
um and and that can get very nuanced as well you
know we get deep into what is really truly holding
you back from doing some of these strategic moves
that you really haven't done yet and then another
thing that i've noticed with some of my clients is
that the longer you have been in the industry and
i always say hollywood but i don't say hollywood
as in the location i call like the industry
hollywood so the longer you've been in hollywood
if you've been in hollywood for five or ten years
you end up having more limiting
beliefs than somebody who is brand new
because someone who is brand new they're so green
and they're so naive that they take more risks
because they're not afraid of doing the wrong
thing because they don't know what the wrong thing
is whereas someone who's been here for a long
time and has been in the industry for a long time
you know more about how the industry works
and you might know more about like behind
the scenes and what relationships are
important and what you need to be doing
and then because of that you you lose
your sense of risk-taking and being
bold and putting yourself out there you know
um in a i hate to say in a risky way but
it's all about risk-taking you know it's all
about putting yourself out there and taking risks
and so the longer you've been in hollywood
the more rules you are trying to live by
but the thing is is that for every rule
in hollywood there's always an exception
so you don't necessarily want to
use these rules to hold you back
and when i say rules just for an example in the
industry you know some of my actor clients when
they are wanting to they need to get a new agent
or a new manager one of the rules in hollywood
is you should never contact representation
and reach out to them during pilot season
right there's like certain times of the year
that's busier maybe the beginning of episodic or
you know when pilot season is going on and
you're not supposed to reach out right and
so it's just because you know how the industry
works you've been in the industry a long time
you know that there's a pilot season you know
that people are really busy during pilot season
but there's always going to be an exception to
that rule that rule is not really set in stone
and so if you follow that rule because you think
you're you know you have this knowledge about
how the industry works and you want to be good
and follow these rules that you think you know
in that process you are stopping yourself from
taking a risk and i've had many clients book
agents during pilot season and then
are able to go out for pilot season
so that's just a little example you know of
i think some of the things that hold people
back in hollywood the more they know the more it
tends to hold them back and then also with that
there's a third part of this that i've
really noticed with some of my clients
is that the more you know the
more boxes you try to fit into
and i feel like that's just a big thing
in hollywood that a lot of people struggle
no matter if you're a writer a director um you
know working behind the scenes somehow an actor
you know even my production designer boss a couple
years ago fell into that of like how can i you
know oh i do drama and they don't think i can do
comedy and so i have found that a lot of people
get stuck in these boxes because they're trusting
other people to tell them what box they fit into
you know like with actors it all all starts in the
beginning with headshots i've seen this so many
times where an actor is told to put their headshot
on facebook and ask everyone on facebook what what
roles can you see me as with this headshot you
know what shows do you see me in according to this
headshot and that's a super common thing right
and if they're not asking their facebook friends
they're asking their agents their managers their
you know their teachers but every time you do that
you are asking somebody else to tell you how to
live your dream and you're letting somebody else
dictate what roles you go out for what projects
you get to be a part of and you completely lose
your voice and so i think that when people
struggle in the five to ten year range i
think that that sometimes depending on the person
you know plays a part where all these years maybe
they've been trying to pursue the industry in
these boxes that they were told they should be in
but it never feels good and it never feels
aligned and so they struggle you know i have
one of my clients really struggle with that and
you know she's done such beautiful work as we work
together for the past two years and she's really
come into her own right like you know she's really
connected with who she really is now and who she
wants to be and not who hollywood has been telling
her to be all these years and then that leads
to more exciting opportunities because you're
more confident and standing on in your own um more
often and you know that will bleed into the work
that you do even though it sounds counterintuitive
like oh erica but hollywood loves the boxes
stepping out of that is somehow going to help you
succeed i think yes i think it's about alignment
and and being yourself a hundred percent i
think that will always lead to more success
i love what you're saying what if what if we
can't accurately see ourselves because like i
knew someone who was was auditioning and she was
doing well and she was about to turn 30 which
when you look back at it from an older age is not
old at all but a friend or so she thought said oh
let me see your headshots and so she showed this
friend and the friend said oh and he gave her
this feedback he said look you're getting near
30 so you're gonna want to aim for mom rules
so maybe tone down the sexy
factor a little bit and
that was sort of eye-opening to this person
because they still saw themselves as this
you know not sex kitten but they
just saw themselves as not as the mom
and so i'm just wondering how much is it that
we're blinded by ourselves because we can't really
see ourselves accurately sometimes or was she
allowing this person to really tell her how to be
yeah i think i mean it's a great question
and and i'm sure that you know every agent
or casting director or whatever will disagree
with me but i think that the more we buy into
the boxes the more we are helping perpetuate the
problem and so i think that you know with the
rise of streamers like netflix and and hulu and
amazon we are getting to see more complex stories
which is amazing because with the networks of abc
nbc you know those are likely following formulas
that have worked before and they're a little more
of stereotype when it comes to characters and
content and you know and story but because
there's so much more content now available
with the streaming i really do feel that we are
finally moving into an area of hollywood where we
are getting more complex storytelling and so to me
like the mom right you turn 30 and then you need
to play the mom it's like could you be a super
complex character that happens to have a child
right and so i think that we need to stop
letting hollywood define us as the mom
um even if that feels hard you know even if
you feel like you're getting the advice from
someone trusted who's been in the industry i
think it is partly on us to stop perpetuating
those kinds of things that happen you know like
the client that i was talking about she just came
out as non-binary and that can be really scary
as an actor you know because she's having to
explore with her representation what that means
in terms of what roles she wants to go out for
but to her for her to even have that conversation
with her representation she is breaking through
the the boxes and the hollywood stuff you
know of stereotypes and she is challenging it
because she is saying this is who i am this is who
i know that i am and so let's explore what kind of
complex roles i can play so i guess to answer
your question about you know finding ourselves
if we feel like maybe we've lost ourselves i
think you have to begin by tuning out everything
tuning out the noise don't listen to me don't
listen to other people you have to get back to
yourself and what your dream truly is you know the
very first chapter of my book i invite people to
write down everything they would love to happen
in their career everything that you dream of
you know get back to that dream you had in your
heart when you were a kid or whenever it was that
you decided you wanted to pursue this dream get
back to that and connect to that and really you
know some of my clients too they'll they'll study
they'll do some research and watch you know some
shows that they really love and start to explore
what excites them you know when you watch this do
you feel really excited because you'd love to play
a complex role like this person um so i think that
process involves you know you um reconnecting with
your own intuition and tuning out the noise and
get really true to who you are and decide that
you are worthy and are capable of succeeding as
who you are even if others tell you no you need to
play the mom or know you need to fit in this box
erica what's the biggest obstacle you've had to
overcome in your own life that's a good one my
biggest obstacle for sure that i have
had to overcome that i'm still working on
is my self-worth and you know
my struggle with self-worth um
i've done a lot of work to try to work you know to
try to heal that and and work on that and i think
that being an artist in hollywood requires
you to put yourself out there in a way that
most people won't really have to do in
their lifetime if they weren't pursuing
a big dream you know if they weren't trying to do
something um challenging it requires a lot of you
and you know through you know with rejection and
and also through depending on what your job is in
the industry what your craft is it can feel so
personal you know like what you are putting out
your work that you are putting out it is like
you right it's attached to you so i think that
you know i tend i tend to attract a lot of clients
who are like myself and i think a lot of artists
in general struggle with self-worth more so
because it's on display so much more often
than maybe other people who aren't working in an
industry like hollywood would have to you know
face essentially um which i guess it's a good
thing it's a good thing that we need to that i
should say i that i need to work on this and
that i need to um get better but it's really
been my biggest obstacle because i think that
it impacts everything i do it impacts how i put
myself out there how i ask for things that i
want if i you know come across as someone who
believes they're worthy of what they want
or you know i talk to my clients a lot about
how a lot of artists come across as desperate in
the please choose me please choose me am i good
enough tell me i'm good enough and i think a lot
of us you know struggle with that so i i myself
have struggled with that as well um and i think
especially shifting into my coaching business
where i have to build a business on me where i'm
the brand and um it's it's been a whole extra
layer of me working through some self-worth stuff
i guess you could say but that's definitely been
my biggest obstacle i'm wondering if struggles
with self-worth actually propel someone to go
pretty far because when i've done like little
bits of research on a lot of people whether it's
acting music whatever i find a
lot of them have a missing parent
and i think that that causes people to do
interesting things and so i'm wondering if
that almost propels people to to go further where
someone who doesn't it's more safe and so oh okay
i didn't get this well that's all right but
somebody who really is like obsessed with it
it actually that that self-worth sort of wound
actually makes them rise up more i hope i'm i'm
making sense now you're making perfect i mean
tony robbins talks a lot about the idea of
if you grew up without a lot of trauma or
obstacles or issues you're almost in a worse
spot trying to achieve big goals um he's you know
because because of exactly what you're talking
about this like safe comfortable kind of bubble
and and a lot of people you know look at people
like oprah who had an incredibly challenging
childhood right so a lot of the times that people
who grew up with a lot of obstacles or potentially
a lot of trauma it does propel them you know it
does um ignite a fire perhaps or or helps them
succeed i think with self-worth particularly it
could totally go in that direction but i find at
least with the clients that i work with is that
more often than not it actually does hold
people back from taking bigger risks or putting
themselves out there in a bigger way and so they
do it kind of in a safe way of yeah and i myself
struggle with this and i know that i can catch
myself when i do this you know sometimes i'll
you know make a post for my business or something
and i'll do it to an audience that i know already
loves and accepts me and so you know i think
that if you if you doubt yourself and you don't
feel worthy of what you want it usually ends up
holding you back so like if people procrastinate
procrastination is really has nothing to do with
laziness and everything to do with resistance and
a lot of times when people procrastinate it's
really truly because they don't feel worthy of
the thing that they're trying to make happen um so
i do feel like you know i think it can definitely
go in the direction that you're talking about and
i think other obstacles and trauma absolutely does
propel somebody forward but a lot of times with
self-worth it it it holds us back from you know
going after the big things that we want right
yeah i'm thinking of like marilyn monroe and
the lack of self-worth probably took her very
far but it also could have taken her down
unfortunately yeah i mean i guess too you know if
you don't have a strong sense of self or strong
self-worth you're going to let a lot of people
tell you how to live your life you know tell you
you know back to these like hollywood boxes
like like for example if you don't have a
strong self-worth maybe you do end up booking
projects booking shows booking um features
but none of them feel aligned like you
don't actually feel happy you feel miserable
right because you let somebody else tell you
what you should feel or what you should go after
because you didn't feel that you were
worthy of the things that you really want
so tony raw i i guess i maybe i have heard
that from him before but so you've heard him
say that it's actually not an impediment to
have had if having had like sort of this safe
upbringing but or maybe it is i don't know yeah
i don't want to i don't want to butcher his
words and say it incorrectly i'm just i'm just
recalling you know my memory of what he said
but that was that was like i
have remembered that because i
you know it's interesting like i am
someone who is incredibly determined and
ambitious um but i i did have somewhat of a
comfortable life and sometimes i wonder if
that propelled me actually this is like a totally
different topic but if that propelled me in a way
where like i feel less scared to go after certain
things or to take some risks because i feel like
i i still have a safety net of my family like
i have a good family life you know so i feel
like i still have this safety net so maybe it's
less scary for me than other people but i don't
know from what i remember of what he said um i'm
pretty sure he did say that you know people that
that struggled more in their childhood or
in their lives kind of have that one up on
i don't know maybe being ambitious or pursuing
your goals what's the biggest challenge you've
helped one of your clients through one of
the biggest challenges that i have helped
my clients with and this probably doesn't sound
very sexy but i feel like i i feel very fortunate
to connect with people who are struggling in their
careers and are really down about it um and the
fortunate part comes with how i get to help them
not that i'm so glad that people are struggling
that maybe came out wrong but um i've been
very fortunate to connect with these people who
feel really down about their careers because maybe
it has been some time and they're not where they
want to be yet and so sometimes people come to
me where they're depressed and they're really
feeling down and by the end of the time we're
working together they they feel happy again
they feel excited again in their career you know
they feel hopeful and that energy switch is so
crucial to what comes next in terms of their
strategic moves and what opportunities come
their way like it really does help them bring in
a new level up opportunity and so i think you know
like i've had clients who are on the verge of
quitting and i'm like one of their last resorts
you know and so i think for me that's one of the
most challenging things that i've helped clients
with but i think that is so rewarding because
it's so it's so awesome to see people who've
started feeling really down and really depressed
about their career who now like one of my new
clients i mean we're only like a month in and
she's already feeling so excited and hopeful and
that is just so awesome i mean you know i just
feel so fortunate to be able to help people
like i feel like one of my superpowers is
helping people believe in themselves and
and really seeing what's possible and so i feel
honored to kind of relight that spark for people
and help them get back to what's possible and and
get back to their dream well it's like dating you
know like when you're in a relationship all of
a sudden now all these people are attracted to
when you weren't yeah no one would call no
nothing happened but then all of a sudden you
give off this energy of like i don't really need
it that much or whatever and i think that yeah
the desperation goes yeah something happens and
whether it's dating or business or whatever but
i don't know if the same for some of what you've
talked about i mean a little bit you know it's
it's a to for me it's about the energy and so and
it's about getting in alignment with the energy
of the thing that you desire so if you're
feeling really down and really low which is
normal and happens all the time you're
not likely to attract you know exciting
new opportunities right it's like if if you're
feeling like really low and you're right here
um and these opportunities that you want are
up here you're not in alignment with them
and and so when you start to feel good again
and inspired and excited it brings you up
here and now suddenly you are in alignment with
these new opportunities and i think from like a
slightly more tangible way to explain this is that
when you are feeling really down and really low
you are problem oriented right and so and i i
know that i've been this way when i went through
my really challenging year 2009 and i was really
depressed my mom would suggest solutions to me
and she would think of ideas to help me and i
would say no to everything i would shoot down
everything i was just not in the energy
of accepting help or accepting a solution
because i was feeling so low and so when
you're feeling hopeful and excited again
suddenly it's like oh there's opportunity
everywhere i see solutions everywhere
so you're my you know the your belief system and
your energy it's all controlling the opera like
opportunities might have existed around you the
whole time but you just didn't see them you know i
always talk about the example of the fedex logo do
you know the fedex logo um so i mean i would know
the colors it's like the purple and the orange
and you know that there's like the hidden arrow
in between the e and the axe of fedex in the white
space maybe i don't no so i say this because a lot
of people tend to know about the arrow and and
so if you don't know about the arrow go look
at the fedex logo and so it's in the negative
space the white space between the e and the x
um and that was intentionally done because fedex
is about you know movement and so there's also
a little hidden baking spoon in the lowercase e
that most people don't know really okay and the
idea is that even if you didn't know about that
arrow and that baking spoon they were always there
you might have looked at that logo a hundred times
and you didn't see that because you didn't know it
was there you didn't know to look but it doesn't
mean that they didn't exist they were always there
so it's like when you are feeling hopeful
and excited and you're feeling good
you know to look for opportunities that are always
around you but if you're feeling depressed and low
you're probably not even going to see them
even though they might be right in front of you
what do you do for people that they can't
necessarily do for themselves two things i
think one is like i talked about i think that i
help people believe in themselves and believe in
what's possible in a way they never have before
i feel very proud i feel like it is my superpower
you know to really help people expand their view
of what is truly possible and the other thing
that i do that people might not be able to do for
themselves is to see their blind spots right so
i can usually have a conversation with them and
fairly quickly determine where their blind spots
are in terms of like what's holding them back
you know if they talk to me about their strategy
you know i can pick out what's really holding
them back in that strategy what the limiting
belief is you know just the other day i was
on a podcast interview and i was coaching the
the one of the hosts and he talked about how
him and his producing partner they they live
somewhere else in the united states and
they're working on moving to las vegas
and and they had this whole plan about why that
was a good decision and i said tell me why you're
moving to las vegas instead of la tell me why
you're not moving to la right and so they told
me all these reasons that were really fear-based
they didn't believe that they could afford to live
here they didn't believe they'd find any work
they didn't you know they they have all these
stories that they decided on um that created
their decision and then that decision leads to
dream adjacent right and so i think that um we
can't always see our blind spots that's why i
work with coaches too you know i have people
help me with my blind spots and so we can't we
can't see them on our own you know because our
mind is really good at justifying our decisions
our mind is really good at coming up with reasons
or excuses about why what we're doing is the right
thing to do or the best thing for us but a lot of
times you know we're holding ourselves back and so
i help people with that and and really helping
them recognize where their blind spots may be
how do you define success my definition
of success has changed over the last two
years and i would not be surprised if it changed
again in the next coming years i think that for
the last 10 years i really define success by the
projects i was booking and the money i was making
and once i got those things that i desired then
i realized wait a minute i really just want to
be happy not that some of those things didn't make
me happy but now i'm really chasing for lack of a
better word what makes me happy and and that's to
me more important i think that i'm still weaving
into my you know one of my coaches was like oh
so you say that's what or maybe my therapist
said this you say that success is just about
what makes you happy but you're still kind of
living in this world where you want to make a
certain amount of money and you want to book
certain projects and and so i think that i have
one foot in that world and one foot in this world
but for me it's so much more about being happy
and helping people and so i'm i'm trying to
refocus my energy on that because i think it's
really easy to get caught up especially in the
social media world where we're comparing ourselves
to other people all the time and what their lives
look like and where they're spending their money
and what projects you know i think um you know
a lot of my actor clients we talk about how their
least favorite question ever is have i seen you in
anything or are you working on anything now people
feel very insecure about that question and so
i just you know i myself have gotten very
caught up in what projects i'm working on
so that i can tell other people and then i
will be perceived as successful and being
perceived as successful is more important than
how i actually feel doing these things and so
um so now i'm just trying to let go of that and
focus on what makes me happy like i think that
you know it's like if we look back at
our lives i don't know i would rather be
happy and and doing things that
feel good and excite me than
constantly worrying about trying to compare myself
to others and what it looks like to other people
what do you think about the fact that that's
a great place to be in but some people might
need to have kiss the ring so to speak and then
realize you know what it wasn't that great and i
actually just want to be happy but they needed
that experience to know i actually was up here
for a little bit and i decided i wasn't happy but
i needed to know what that felt like yeah i think
that we all are on our own journey we all are on
our own path you know if i had to experience that
to learn this lesson it's not even necessarily
a lesson it's just a redirect for myself
um and so i i don't think there's anything wrong
with like some people just have to live out their
journey and live out their own experiences than
to decide what they want you know i think that's
what we're always collecting data based on
how we feel so everything that we do we're
collecting data and then we're re-evaluating
so i think that's totally okay but what i do
sort of direct people in my book is to and
again this is something that i feel like
that i've been working on is to stop setting
goals that are based on validation right so
try to at least start chasing the joy because i
think that the all those things that you think
you want they're going to come anyway right you
can be happy and get all those things but we don't
necessarily always know why we want those things
and so i think it is important to take a look at
like well why do i want that you know like i
remember i have a dream of buying a house it
used to be in the hills but now i want one in the
palisades or you know with ocean view as opposed
to city view and i remember someone said to me
oh do you want that because of how it'll look
and i said oh my gosh no that that's not part of
this dream for me at all i want it because i have
family back on the east coast and i want rooms
for them to come visit for extended periods of
time so that i can be you know i'm very close
with my family and i hate that they're so far
away and i don't get to see them very often and
i'm also very sensitive to my surroundings that
i want surroundings that inspire me and excite
me and so it's really what it's about and so
i think yeah i think if you're feeling like
well i want the money or i want the accolades
it's just about getting really honest with
yourself about why you want those things
everything that we say we want is because of how
we think we're going to feel when we get it so if
you you know if you want an oscar why why do what
do you think you're going to feel when you get
that oscar and and i think that if you can break
down those feelings it's more important to sort
of chase those feelings or to try to feel those
now than necessarily the the label that you think
is going to give you those feelings um if that
makes sense so i think you know like i said in
my book it's really about like set any goal that
you want there's nothing wrong with any of them
but if you're chasing them for
validation to make you feel
good to make you feel more worthy
or more deserved deserved deserve it
it probably isn't going to feel the way
that you think it's going to feel it's
not going to solve the inner problem right
like none of the external things that we
create for ourselves or that we get aren't going
to are never going to solve an internal problem
i think most of this is is validation from
others or self-validation validation from others
you think that matters more to most people i think
a lot i think a lot of us make decisions based on
how others will perceive it how like for example
everyone and their mother in this industry says
that they want to work on netflix you know on
a netflix project and you know there might be
some like there might be some reasons behind
that in the terms of well they do great work
you know they they tell complex stories and i'm
interested in the stories that they're telling
but a lot of people especially the actors
that i work with or the directors the writers
they say they want netflix because netflix is
a huge well-known entity right now and if they
book something netflix they can then post
it on social media or they can tell people
hey i booked a netflix show and that
makes them feel successful because
they're perceived as successful because it's
a network or streamer that everybody knows
right but what if what was really important
to you that you booked a project that told a
meaningful story that impacted people's lives and
that was really fun to create and it felt really
great like you were working with great people
collaborating with great people and the whole
experience just felt good well what if you could
get that experience at abc or on hulu or you know
or another smaller now you know because i talk
about one of my best experiences in hollywood
was a show that was on abc family which is now
free form you know and i don't think many people
are like i want to work on freeform like
everyone's like i want to work on netflix
you know it's not maybe as sexy maybe
they don't have quite as many viewers but
it was the most fun i ever had on a show and we
were telling a meaningful story and there were
really amazing crew and cast members it was just
a really good experience so yeah i think that it's
this is a long way to say i i think it is about
chasing validation from others and how we are
perceived by others and does that go back to sort
of that boxes thing that you said like being in la
you you think that there's these certain rules
in these boxes and it's the same thing about like
oh oh you're just doing the um the score network
i've never heard of it yeah oh okay yeah no but
if you were somewhere else oh wow you're on a tv
show how cool right but here there's these levels
right the hierarchy yeah yeah i i don't know
if it's necessary i guess the box is in a way
where you're like boxing yourself into what your
dream has to look like like my dream has to look
like me working for netflix um so i guess in a
way but i do think yeah that people don't realize
that it's probably going to be a more enjoyable
experience if you intentionally try to create
a good experience for yourself you know like
a show that you love working on that you're
doing meaningful work then whatever
the label of the network or the studio
is you know because you know look like i've
i've known series regulars who have quit
and who just like after a few seasons weren't
feeling fulfilled anymore it wasn't like a story
they felt like was meaningful in their lives
you know and so that happens you know like you
might get the thing that you think you want like
you might get netflix and then it not be a good
experience i'm not trying to put that out there
i'm sure like there's a lot of amazing experiences
on netflix but my point is like get clear about
how you want the experience to feel and what you
want the experience to look like like i say in
my book like write make a list of everything
that you want in the next project you want to
book or whatever goal you're working towards
write the list of everything that everything
you think netflix is going to give you
right write down everything you think it's
going to give you and then take away netflix
at the top and then but still but still chase
your list right so you're still really going
after what you truly want but you're allowing it
to look however it looks how do you help people
with the part of success where they want what
other people have i mean that is happening all
the time and i have found myself um getting
caught up in that too you know i think that
when people post things on social media i think
that's like really a lot of where it comes from
as opposed to seeing it in actual real
life i think that when we see somebody's
highlight reel on social media
we are putting a whole story behind that post
about what it means and how it must feel for them
to have what that thing right so if somebody posts
a picture of themselves uh driving a porsche you
know a fan's very fancy car and they're smiling
in it and they're like yeah you know they look
cool you might then create this whole story about
what that means for that person and how their life
must be so amazing and it must feel so good for
them and wow they have so much money and we create
this whole narrative about what it means when we
see them having this thing and we're like well we
want those feelings i i want to feel financially
stable i want to feel wealthy i want to
um feel excited about a new purchase i i
want to have a car like that right so we
we think that they're feeling a certain way
when they have something and then we want to
feel that way and so we think the way we feel
it is to try to get the same thing they have
and it's so easy to get caught up in whatever we
think you know people are or whatever we're seeing
people have you know even if it's a a
booking you know if you book a job or
you have an audition or something you know i
think that if you see someone post online that
um i'm trying to think of something that maybe
i've thought i wanted but i didn't actually want
like like for example one of my clients said you
know what they're an actor and they were like you
know what every actor wants to be series regular
they think it's like hitting the lottery you know
financial lottery because it's it's a lot of money
and it's consistent work and one of my clients was
like you know what i don't think i want to be
a series regular at this time in my life like
because you usually have to wake up at like four
in the morning you know you're there all day it's
a very long day you have to wake up she's like
i don't know if i really i kind of like waking
up at eight o'clock and said you know i don't know
if that's really what i want in my life right now
so she had to you know get honest about wait
a minute what makes me happy what would make
me happy now um so i think social media plays a
big role in it but but it's really what we decide
it means right what we decide it means that this
person booked this project or has this opportunity
we also don't know the truth about what it means
to that person or what they're really feeling
on the other side of it you know maybe they're
like posting i i had this amazing audition for
this for netflix wow i'm so lucky i have such
a great life but really they're feeling like
maybe it was like a two-line role and it was
something that they're not actually excited about
but they're trying to tell the world that they had
this netflix audition and then people that see it
are like oh man they have this great life they're
getting these netflix auditions and then we create
the story about what we think they're feeling
or what you know so i think it comes down to
what are the feelings you want to
feel when you get the thing you want
and stop assuming that every single person who
has something feels that exact way because i
think we're attaching those feelings to what other
people have how do you help clients who are hyper
focused on other people's achievements i help them
get reacquainted with what their true dream is
i think it's so easy to look at what everybody
else is doing and to decide that that's what
success means and so that's what i should go
after but we really want to reconnect with what
our true dream is like what is it that we truly
want like tune out the noise stop looking at what
other people are doing stop looking at social
media what people are doing on social media
what they're posting and really reconnect to
what is it that you truly want you know i have
this line in my book that i was actually really
proud of i think it's a good line where i said
when you are trying to replicate someone else's
magic you are taking yourself out of the running
for your own and i i think that's so important
i think that as long as you are chasing somebody
else's dream or you're trying to you know have
or do what other people are having and doing
you are cutting yourself off from your own
fulfilling really cool journey you know really
amazing magical experience you know it's going
to be so much more fulfilling if you reconnect
to what it is that you want and go after it
in a way that feels good to you as opposed
to comparing yourself to everybody else and
trying to replicate what other people are doing
i think as long as you are trying to replicate
somebody else's path you're going to get stuck
i i think we all have our own path and we we need
to find our own path especially in an industry
like hollywood where there's no one way to do
anything you know if you lined up 10 successful
people or 100 successful people and ask them how
did you break in or how did you get to where you
are you're probably going to hear a hundred
different stories so it's important that we leave
room for us to find our own story and that comes
from really letting go and disconnecting from
what you see everybody else doing what's
your definition of a high achiever
i that's such a good question um because i use
that term all the time um my definition of a high
achiever is somebody who first of all has a desire
for something beyond the base level you know
like people say oh i want to be a working actor
and i'm like really like that's such a base level
thing i understand you want to pay your bills
from acting and sure that would be amazing but
like that's one aren't you you're gonna want so
many more things you know beyond that so i think
like number one it's about the desire the desire
for something greater than what's comfortable for
most people and then i think that you know a lot
of my work in terms of helping people become high
achievers is about how you think about what you're
doing what your belief system is behind what you
are doing so that it leads to higher level risks
higher level actions and strategies that then
usually lead to higher level opportunities but so
you know in my book i talk about the 10 pillars
of the high achiever and it's it's really
about how you view what is possible and um
how you view what you're capable
of you know what you're able to do
so if you're a high achiever you view the world
in a way that you believe that anything's possible
and you make decisions based on your desires and
based on your dreams instead of based on fear
you know you do things that are not based
on those hollywood rules you know you really
go beyond what i call like the most people pool
so you're not doing what most people are doing
um you're doing what the smaller pool of high
achievers are doing which is you know you're
really you're really looking at the world in
a different way and and your own dreams in a
different way like if you have a dream of winning
an oscar or being a millionaire you believe that
not only that it's possible but that it will
happen for you and just that belief changes
that it changes the entire trajectory you know
of what what potential you have in front of you
so base level let's say filmmaker screenwriter
what would so that would be they want to work on
a few projects not they're looking to i mean
like maybe my working actor example wasn't
the greatest because i'm definitely not trying
to judge anybody's like level but i think that
you know like beyond student films beyond
unscripted you know we're talking about
hollywood for for screenwriters or for any
other kind of craft you know i think that
um beyond what most people strive for
you know because i think that striving
for like a base level keeps people safe
you know i i think that most people that
have dreams of succeeding in hollywood in this
industry they have their dreams are beyond
student films or their dreams are beyond you know
just paying their bills you know i think a lot of
people dream of telling really interesting stories
you know i think people love storytelling and the
art of storytelling you know a lot of the people
that i work with they want to make an impact on
people's lives they want to make a difference in
the world through storytelling you know i think
that that goes beyond i just want to be able to
pay all my bills from my craft i think everybody
wants to be able to pay all the you know bills
from their craft but um i think the high achievers
they want more they want to they want to go beyond
that they don't want to stay safe and comfortable
at whatever level is safe and comfortable what
are some of the achilles heels of a high achiever
interesting question
one of the things that i personally have struggled
with and i consider myself a high achiever is
all like the fact that i'm kind of always reaching
for something right and so i think that that
might be an achilles heel of the high achiever
where that bar is always moving and and so that
like one thing that i've been working on is being
more present you know being more present in where
i am and trying to enjoy the moment because
my eyes are usually always on the next thing
you know i'm always reaching i'm always on that
next thing i always want to know my next goal
you know right now i'm in this period
where i don't really know for sure
what that next goal is for me and i've never
experienced that before it's very uncomfortable
to have to just sit here and be present and wait
for it to sort of come or be inspired um and so i
think that's probably a high achiever's achilles
heels that you know they're not really sometimes
struggling with being present and enjoying the
journey and enjoying where they are because their
eyes are always on the next thing is there
no other way around that as a high achiever
is that just part of the journey so to speak
yeah i mean i don't i don't want to put my own
struggles on anybody else and make a blanket
statement and say that you know all high
achievers will you know struggle with that i think
everybody we all have our own stuff you know um
so yeah i think you know everyone's going to
have their own struggles but it's really about
how willing are you to do the work to better
yourself and to get where you want to go
how do you train someone to believe
that their success is inevitable
i drill it in them a hundred times until
we believe it i think that whenever you're
trying to take on a new belief sometimes
our subconscious mind needs proof and so
i try to tell people what that means in tangible
terms like why is your success inevitable and
what will happen if you don't believe your success
is inevitable right like if you don't believe your
success is inevitable it is very likely that you
have a plan b you know that you have some sort of
backup plan that you have set up a timeline for
yourself where if this doesn't happen in five
years i'm gonna move back home or i'm gonna
do something else um right you're coming up
with like insurance because you don't believe a
hundred percent it's like a prenup for your dream
because you don't believe 100 that it's going to
work out and what happens is that when you don't
believe your success is inevitable you don't
take the big risks you don't put yourself out
there in the same way because you don't believe
that it can happen right so it really impacts
the strategy or the actions that you end up
taking so i try to help people by showing them
where you know where their current belief of
not believing their success is inevitable is
leading them and how that's playing out and
i like to inspire people to show them like
why i think their success is inevitable and
i think that if you can take away the lottery
feel of succeeding right because i think that
you'll hear often oh succeeding in hollywood
that's like winning the lottery so for example
one of my clients i think this is in my book
she said that that was something that
she had heard a lot you know that
good luck trying to make it in hollywood that's
like winning the lottery and so i said to her
can you count on your hand can you name any
people you know who have won the lottery
she was like you know i don't think
i know anyone who's won the lottery
i said okay now can you count on your hand and
name me people who have succeeded in hollywood
and she listed like 10 people that she personally
knew who were doing well in the industry and so
you know because we want to give our subconscious
brain the subconscious part of our mind
some sort of tangible proof to hold on to and
so when we go through that it's like oh okay so
it's actually not as hard as winning the lottery
it's not that random because i i can name so many
more people that have succeeded right so suddenly
your subconscious goes oh okay that's different
so we start looking for proof of why like
why is your success inevitable like why is
it inevitable that you will succeed well if you
take a look at you know all the people who are
successful and who are you know if we take
a look at their actions or everything that
they've done and if you're doing the same things
it is inevitable that it will lead to success
and that success might look different to every
person and however you define success but um
you know i really try to help people retrain
their brain to understand that succeeding in
hollywood doesn't have to be this insane unlikely
thing you know i think that we kind of come into
it with that notion and so we want to train our
brain to understand that that's not actually true
do you think some people might want to fail
because it brings more sympathy more people
like you if too successful people won't like you i
that's an interesting question i've never thought
of it that way i think a lot of people want to
fail because if their subconscious mind does not
believe that they can succeed if they fail they're
proving it right and people like to be right
so they like to say see told you i couldn't
succeed right and so like i always used to
give this example sorry i'm giving so many actor
examples i work with a lot of actors but um you
know if you don't believe that you 100 are going
to succeed as an actor you might take a day job
that is a nine to five and if you have a nine to
five day job you can't really audition i guess
now it's a little different during the pandemic
with self tapes everything self tapes right now
but you know pre pandemic and hopefully post
pandemic auditions will be in person again and
they're going to be during the day during the week
right and so if you have a nine-to-five job you're
taking this on because you think you're doing
the responsible thing and we could talk about day
jobs is like a whole nother conversation where
we can have where a lot of people have an idea
in their mind that the only way to financially
support themselves is through nine to five work
but that's like a self-sabotaging move right and
so then you're not getting auditions because you
can't go on them unless you're calling
out for a doctor's appointment every day
and then you end up you know a couple years in
and you're not succeeding in hollywood and then
you can go see i was right i'm not succeeding
in this town in this industry so i think that um
people self-sabotage just to like prove their
subconscious mind right um but there's there's
so many reasons why people want to fail that some
people are afraid of success they're afraid you
know kind of what you're talking about are they
afraid of like not being liked but also what does
that mean in the dynamics of your family you know
what will your family think if you succeed what
does that look like um you know how will you feel
if you're quote unquote more successful than your
parents or you know someone that raised you or
something you know people struggle with so many
nuanced things about failing and succeeding so i
think there are many reasons but those are a few
right or or maybe if um the the brother
or the sister was always the golden
child and then the black sheep actually surpasses
it yes that that's a taboo no it's not okay
yeah there's that's interesting people will be
afraid of success like that because we would think
oh no no that will not i'm that wouldn't happen to
me no i just you know yeah and some people think
that if i do succeed there are other things in
life i won't be able to have you know like if i'm
successful in hollywood i won't be able to have
um a happy marriage and raise kids you know people
have that fear sometimes of like you know the
scheduling with hollywood that i won't be able to
have a family things like that so sometimes
people self-sabotage because they're afraid that
even if they do succeed there are other things
that they won't be able to have or that it'll
you know negatively impact relationships that's
true or the nanny will know my kids better than
right yeah right what are some examples
of star qualities star qualities i think
one of the things that i outline i have a
whole chapter called star power chapter two
one of the examples that i give in
the book is when you think about
someone who is a star like taylor swift or steven
spielberg right so it's not even necessarily a
star as in they're a performer and they're in
front of the camera someone that's a star in
their industry who were they before they had any
credits who was taylor swift before anybody knew
her name she was taylor swift right and so i
think it's about how you show up in the beginning
and i talk about you know like we all have this
greatness within us and you don't need a resume
or an imdb credit or any other kind of validation
to prove that you can be a star you know that you
have greatness i think that we all have greatness
already within us and so you know star power is
about embracing that connecting to your own star
power that you have before a single person knows
your name or before you have anything on your
resume you can still have that star power but it's
about showing up as a star now before waiting for
somebody else to validate you and to say that you
are a star or to say that you are great um
it's about believing that in yourself now
before you do anything can you give me
an example of a star quality that seems
that's kind of unknown that would be unlikely that
you would never think that you know we think of
someone with just amazing confidence owns a room
head turner in so many ways charming i think that
for me it's it's not even about necessarily those
things it's a well the confidence piece it's about
the it's about owning your dream owning what
you want and deciding you are worthy of it
because that will translate to risks that you take
in actions you take the example i give in my book
is about steven spielberg and about his story
about how he you know basically broke in he was
able to get a meeting on the universal studios lot
with chuck silvers who i think was working in post
and he got to connect with him for three
days and he was so excited he got to be on
the lot and i think he got to show him like a
short film he had made or something like that
and chuck said okay well the three days are up you
know i can't get a pass for you to come back onto
the lot you know if you want to come back you'll
have to kind of find your own way i can't get
you like a permanent pass so steven spielberg
was like all right i need to get back on this
lot i need to connect with these people i need to
show them my work i need to get in front of them
so the next day he shows up in a suit holding a
briefcase goes up to the gate and just waves to
the guy at the gate and it looks like you
know has the appearance of working there
and they just let him in he didn't have to show a
badge that would probably not happen today because
you really do need to have a drive on today but
what i love so much about that story is that
he was taking a risk and being incredibly
bold to try to create opportunity for himself
and he didn't wait until he had jaws on his resume
to feel confident enough to do that you know he
didn't wait until he was the steven spielberg that
we know because i think it's easy for people to go
oh well he's steven spielberg he can do that but
he wasn't that steven spielberg that we know when
he did that so for me it's examples like that it's
like how do you show up in the beginning do you
show up and take bold risks you know showing
up like you are the star now you don't have
to wait until someone else deems you a
star to to take those kinds of risks and
and take those actions i like that so sorry again
it's knowing that start like owning your dream and
saying that i am worthy of it yes and and when you
feel that way what risks do you end up taking like
you know what i mean i think that a lot
of people in steven spielberg's position
would never do something like that until they are
at his now known level of success right somebody
won't feel comfortable taking that big of a risk
unless they already felt validated by hollywood
you know like one time nothing
ever really came of it but
there was some tv show filming near where
i on location near where i lived and
i saw the prop truck and it was open and so i
brought my business cards to the prop truck and
there was no one there and i just left my business
cards on the floor of the prop truck you know so
it's like it's like things like that it's like
how how do you show up like can you be bold and
show up in a way that most people would never do
unless they already felt validated by the industry
that's a great story yeah i heard about someone
else who had a business card and they were mad
and they were in real estate and they're
just like forget this and they threw them
all in a parking lot and someone found one and
said i have a house to list amazing right yeah you
know look i mean like not every bold risk is going
to be received with open arms but if you're not
taking those risks you're never going to get the
potential opportunities that could come from them
right right because you know it this is a town
where you know there's all these pretty people
and and their accolades and and people are
bragging and and they don't want to stay
small they want to just kind of like peacock
feathers and i think it's easy to be in a room
whatever your thing is and and hear that from
the side and you're like i i what am i doing here
you know and then but i like what you're saying
that if you just all you have to do is just
say i'm owning this is what i want to do and i'm
worthy of it and it doesn't matter if this person
you know has this beautiful plumage that they're
kind of showing the world i i my thing is also
going to matter you have the plumage too it's just
not visible yet like i i really believe that we
all have that greatness inside of us i think it's
internal i think you know the plumage that you're
talking about comes from like external you know
imdb credits or you know prestige or celebrity or
whatever but to me it's a hundred percent an
internal thing it has nothing to do with the
external and you can have all those external
things and still show up and feel imposter
syndrome you know and not feel worthy of being
in the room that you're in and and that happens
you know all the time too look at you know child
stars you know a lot of times where it doesn't
it doesn't pan out as they get older because it's
like too much too soon they weren't ready for it
mentally right and so maybe they felt like an
impostor or whatever there's a million different
reasons why that happens but it's like you know
75 of lottery winners end up getting going broke
and again it's like this whole idea
of like they weren't internally ready
for the thing so to me that plumage that you
speak of is really truly internal and not external
erica i have a composite of someone i'd like you
to have coach cool so we'll give her the name of
crystal and she has wonderful ideas which she puts
in notebooks she's written five screenplays but
she ultimately feels like an imposter especially
since she hasn't been able to get any producers
interested in her work and she's had
no luck with screenwriting contests
her goal is to be a hollywood screenwriter crystal
has always done incredibly well at everything
she's undertaken she's a perfectionist somewhat
competitive but her sense of self-worth is
wrapped up in always being the best and always
winning which she's usually been successful at
she's feeling more and more that maybe her
work isn't creative and interesting enough
and it's not original possibly so she's
feeling useless and maybe that she should
stop quote-unquote wasting her time trying to
pursue this career but she doesn't know what
else to do so how would you begin to work with
crystal crystal let's do this um well the very
first question i would ask her and i do have a
process that i take my clients through that i'll
share with you but the very first question
i would ask crystal is do you want to quit
right she's talking about potentially throwing in
the towel she doesn't think her work is getting
her where she needs to go or where she wants to
go and so she's considering doing something else
is that a true desire or is it i don't feel like
i'm good enough i feel like i failed therefore i
should do something else you know i think i joked
with one of my clients because the other day she
had a moment of like oh i want to quit you know i
think so many of our artists feel that from time
to time on their journey and then um last week
she got a very incredible audition opportunity
and she was really excited about it and she put so
much work into it and my whole comment to her was
oh so you don't want to quit so i i but so i it's
like somewhat of a rhetorical question because
i think i know the answer is like no i don't
want to quit but i do think it's important for
someone to say that out loud you know to someone
for someone to really be honest and come to terms
with what you truly desire i mean if you truly do
desire to quit and try something else that's okay
too but then we don't need to work together right
so i think number one is really asking crystal
is this something that you want to keep
doing like do you still have that whisper
is that dream still calling to you is that why
you're coming to me probably you know so i think
that's like important to establish right off
the bat and then before we dive into strategy
and what's working and what's not working and
what are new strategies you could be doing
i spend the first usually hour and a half with
my clients on what is their belief system what
are the fears and doubts that are really holding
you back and i actually go through this in my book
as well you know my book kind of goes through a
lot of the things that i do with my clients so
the first thing i will ask crystal is what do
you want so you say you want to be a hollywood
screenwriter what does that look like do you want
to sell scripts do you want to be a staffed writer
on a show do you want to be a show creator what
does that really look like for you like what is
your dream do you want to be winning emmys you
want to be working on features and so i want to
hear about it i want to reconnect to her dream i
want to hear everything that she wants and i would
ask her like write a bulleted list of everything
you desire and we're just going to put out of
our heads right now that maybe we don't think it's
possible we have no idea it's not really happening
just put all of that out of your head right now
i just want to know what do you want if you could
have your dream what is it that you desire because
once we get really clear on what it is that
she wants that can really help us form a better
strategy that's going to be more tailored to what
she actually desires right instead of creating a
strategy based off of what other people are doing
right i could easily go oh crystal you want to be
a screenwriter here's the screenwriter path let's
do this no i want to know what are her specific
dreams maybe she even has specific dreams of
certain types of stories or certain genres you
know like i've worked with some screenwriters
who are super into the horror genre and that's
all they want to do so i want to hear about it
and so once she writes this list of
everything that she desires then i go
okay now tell me every doubt and fear you have
about that list and we really need to examine
what are the beliefs in your mind right now in
relation to this dream that you're trying to
make happen because that belief system is going to
control what you do next or what you've been doing
right you know like for example when you said
she hasn't had any luck with producers
my question would be how many did you ask
if you don't believe your success is inevitable
that list is probably five to ten people long
my clients are emailing 250 people right
and so your belief system behind everything
is going to control the actions you take and then
inevitably the opportunities you get from those
actions you know like a lot of people and i i've
struggled with this myself um a lot of us we stop
short because we think it's not working or we feel
rejected or we feel discouraged and so we're not
really going the extra mile you know we're not
really taking those risks we're not really doing
everything we could be doing because we feel
deflated and that you know those discouraged
beliefs um they will impact the lack of action
that's happening so i would take her through
uh that list and i would want to hear what what's
every default fear it's gonna say fear endowed
in the same word what is every fear what is every
doubt that comes up for you when you look at this
list and then we take every fear on that list
and we flip it to create an affirmation so that
your new belief system becomes the opposite of
what you believed so for example if crystal's
like well i have a fear that this will never work
out for me okay what do you wish you believed
well i'm being crystal here well i wish that
i believed that it would definitely work out
okay that becomes the new belief my success is
inevitable right and so we're flipping the fears
and so then at the end you have these two lists
side by side you've got all the fears and doubts
and then you've got the opposite you know
essentially affirmations of the new beliefs
and i always say when you look at these two
lists side by side if you looked at them as two
different people person a and person b what kind
of career would person a have with this list of
fears and doubts that's their belief system what
kind of career do you think they're going to have
and it's usually well they probably won't get
very far they're probably going to struggle
and then what about person b these affirmations
this new belief system what kind of career do you
think they're going to have and you know
it's usually they're going to kick butt
they're going to do great and and the whole
point of this is not to say you can never have
these fears again you know i think the doubts
and the fears they're always going to be there
they might change over time but the point is
we want the second list to be in the driver's
seat so the fears and doubts it's okay to have
them they're still going to hang out in the back
seat of the car but we want the affirmations
the new list the new beliefs driving the show
and once you build that foundation and you
really get clear about the belief system that you
currently have and you know the belief system that
you really need to move forward then we can start
to examine the strategy then i want to know like
crystal okay tell me how many producers you've
reached out to tell me how many agents and
managers you've reached out to have you tried
to get representation tell me you know tell me
about i want to hear everything that she's done
and we can take a look about okay well here's what
i think a better strategy would be for you based
on what you told me you desire right and then
we can build a new strategy from there but what
i find you know especially you said that crystal
is perfectionist and i just got to do a clubhouse
the other day with someone who specializes in
perfectionism and i really learned a lot um you
know perfectionism holds us back it's definitely
one of those things that holds us back you know
what we fear and she was saying a lot of times
it's also tied to self-worth like we we think that
we're only worthy if we're perfect if our work is
perfect and if i feel like my work isn't perfect
then i'm not worthy and if i never put my work
out there or take the risks with my work that i
really need to be taking i don't have to confront
whether i'm worthy or not right so tying your
self-worth to perfectionism we would dive deep
you know into all of those things and take a look
and you know the other thing i would say i just
wanted to add because you mentioned the festivals
there is no one way to succeed in hollywood
right and so if festivals is one door that
you're knocking on it's okay if it's not
leading anywhere there are still a million
other doors that you can knock on so i don't
think that any single door is the be-all end-all
you know we don't have to create the story in
our mind and that's what we do when we have
a rejection we create a story in our mind about
what it means so i would want to know hey crystal
you haven't succeeded with festivals what
are you telling yourself that that means
so you know really diving deep into how you feel
about what's been happening and and how we can
work on changing it if that makes sense it does
do you think people that fail are too busy saying
no or to be busy saying yes because you know how
shonda rhimes talked about she had a yearbook
yeah and i think that's great so so but but in
some ways you could say yes to things that could
give you busy work too but do you think as a rule
though most people who failed they haven't said
yes enough i don't think i don't think i would
cat like i usually don't like to make blanket
statements over things like that i call it
absolutes you know saying all ways or never
because i don't think anything is the same for
everybody um so i think some people have trouble
saying no and some people have you know trouble
saying yes and it just you know has to do with
your specific situation you know i had a client
who had she was an actress and she already booked
a lot of television she had like 50 or so episodes
already under her belt um at the co-star co-star
recurring level maybe one or two guest stars
i forget maybe it's just all co-stars and she
really wanted to work on her next level and so we
worked on she ended up getting new representation
but one of the biggest things i worked with her on
once she got this higher level representation was
saying no to auditions and really getting clear
about what her next level looks like and and what
she wants to say yes to and what she doesn't want
to do anymore you know what was part of her old
level so i think i think either way i think people
hold themselves back with the yes and the no
would you ever tell anyone that they weren't
talented enough to do something professionally
i would never tell someone that they're not good
enough never because i had somebody tell me that
in high school and um what i have learned
working in hollywood for now is like 13 years
talent is only one piece of
the puzzle it's one piece
there are so many other qualities that you need
to succeed outside of talent and i think that
if you care enough talent is always
something that you can work on
you know craft you get better through practice and
so you can always be in class you can always be
working with a coach like there's so many ways to
get better in terms of your talent um and from a
law of attraction standpoint the law of attraction
doesn't care if you're talented or not and i hate
to say that because i don't want to discourage
people from taking their craft seriously
but have you ever watched a tv show and thought oh
that acting wasn't very good or that writing was
ooh terrible you know or listen to a song on the
radio and thought i feel like i could sing better
than that person you know my point is is that
talent is just one piece and to me that is not
a deterrent if you're not the most amazing at
your craft yet i think that you can still win i
think you can still succeed now from an integrity
standpoint i think you should be working on your
craft you know from an integrity standpoint
i think you should care about your craft and
you should work on it and you should practice
you know i think some of the greatest artists
in history are people that did it all the time
you know they practiced all the time so i think
you should absolutely be working on your craft
um i just think that there are so many other
qualities that you need to have out like i talk
about this in my book where i say you know going
back to crystal even you know if you are cold
emailing representation and you're trying to get
representation if you email 20 people and they
either all say no or just don't even respond
your talent is not going to get you to keep
going it's your perseverance it's your drive
it's your desire and your ambition right
there's so many other qualities that you
need to keep going in a moment like that so
i think that your talent it only gets you so
far and if the talent is the only thing you have
it will most likely be a hobby and not a career
so i i just i just will never tell somebody that
you know when it's when someone told it to me it's
happened twice actually to me and it was really
soul-crushing you know even in design school
when i i tell the story it's the first story i
tell in the book so sorry to spoil this but um
you know when i first got to art school or the
design program at the college i was going to
i did really well on the first
project and the second project i
almost failed and the teacher said oh i
guess you just got lucky on that first one
i will never forget that i mean i bawled my
eyes out i ran to the bathroom and cried and i
just thought wow like my mentor this person who's
supposed to teach me how to be good is telling me
that anything i've done well so far is chalked up
to luck and that was like so soul-crushing for me
and then i went on to have a pretty incredible
graphic design career in one of the hardest
industries to work in in hollywood and i've
worked on over 30 television shows so i ended up
transferring schools uh because it just it wasn't
that style of teaching wasn't for it didn't feel
good for my growth you know i didn't feel like i
was learning anything or getting better and i just
i don't like using fear as a teaching tactic but
the point is is that i was told that i essentially
wasn't good and i still had an incredible
dream career after that you know i think
that i got better i learned how to get better and
teachers told me how to get better you know and
they taught me and they mentored me and and i got
better and plus i had all these other qualities
that go so much so far beyond talent were they
trying to use like a tough love style of like
tearing you down then to build you back up sort
of thing was it that no it was really you know no
because like i don't think there's really anything
wrong with tough love i mean i guess delivery
could be debated but um tough love is really like
telling you things that you you need you know
you need to hear that you might not want to hear
but will help for your growth and so for me that
program was using fear as a teaching tactic
and so like and i know that a lot of the other
students felt the same way we were kind of scared
to go to class what is the teacher going to think
what are they going to say there's so much
fear um you know even with that assignment
um i didn't get any notes as to like what could
have been better and so i didn't so i'm like oh
i'm almost failing this project but i don't
actually know how to make it better i just
feel bad about myself and i'm scared because
it's t like this teacher's um you know like
instilling fear in me essentially in the way that
she taught and she did that throughout the whole
semester so i just i didn't even like at the end
of the day i feel like i was learning i was like
i want to be a good graphic designer but i
don't know if i'm learning that here um and it
was interesting because almost every student felt
the same way but i was the only one that left so
again a very teachable moment for myself you know
but yeah i don't i don't love some people like
that teaching tactic to use fear as a teaching
tactic i i don't for me it's not productive
i feel like i can learn how to do better
and be better without being afraid um i
feel like it doesn't create like or foster
a safe environment to take risks and fail
so that was my personal experience but then how
can we deliver a message to someone without being
um without protecting them too much where
they're almost blinded because we're not
giving them the real i don't know i mean there's
like yes people yeah a lot of times i'm sure when
people reach a certain level they're surrounded by
yes people and i don't know if that's good or bad
probably some i don't enable them
yeah yeah i don't think that's
surrounding yourself with yes man i don't think
is ever good at least for growth yeah i think
that i mean feedback it's totally okay to give
feedback you know um that teacher was more like
you bad you know it wasn't like constructive
feedback that i felt i could learn from so
um you know the art school that i transferred
to was very tough very tough um but i never felt
bad about myself i don't know it was just
constructive feedback it was like well
this isn't working so well here but if you do x y
and z i think it would work better and here's why
and then i would go oh that would make this
better let me do that you know then i'm excited
about making changes because i'm learning why
it would make it better which i think is really
important and you know as artists it's important
to not attach your self-worth to your work um
you know your work can be a separate thing um
yeah what it going to that second art school
that you said was very competitive teach you um
in terms of competition i should close well i
i wouldn't say it was necessarily competitive
although they're what well there was a little
bit of a sense of competition they they ranked
the top five portfolios when we graduated so
you know there was something about like oh are
you top five and and and i wasn't in the top
five but i had a professor tell my mom oh
she would have been in the top seven if we
did seven she was in our top seven and it's like
like but what what does that actually mean like
i've lived such a different career you know i
went off to design graphics for television other
people are doing other things so i think that
i think what it taught me is that it's good to
strive to be your best but you don't necessarily
have to strive to be the best because i think
the best is going to be subjective no matter you
know where you are what pool you're in so you know
it's it's good to just strive to be your best you
know do better than you did last time you know see
your own growth and then let that lead to your
own path you know even looking sometimes i would
compare myself to um where my other um peers are
now you know with their careers or you know we had
a couple students from our school one that is she
graduated the year before me i believe year or two
before me and she became a pretty famous graphic
designer she's very well known she's a very big
following and the teachers love that and would
always point out you know talk about her and use
her as an example of course and then it's like oh
and i'm always trying to like we would joke about
her name in class my peers and i because it
was like oh we're never going to live up to
that person to our in our teachers eyes and so
i i guess i learned in that sense about you know
like like stop i i want to tell myself that
even now because even now with my book i'm
like still trying to impress my professors and
i graduated like 13 years ago and i'm still like
do they think i'm successful do they like
what i'm doing um and yeah but i think that
lesson i learned there was really like let
yourself be on your own path and you know
just compare yourself to where you were before and
stop trying to be or do what these other people
have is competition good in that it prepares
you for the real world because in the real world
there's no oh you did great and oh you get a
good gold star it's usually much more brutal
than that and it can be very cold unfortunately
yeah definitely i i just have a slightly different
belief about competition i believe there's room
for everybody and that might mean something
different it doesn't necessarily mean there's
room for everybody in the same exact seat
right but i do believe that we all deserve
to live our dreams in our own way so um it
can be competitive in the real world or even in
school but that doesn't mean that you can't live
out your dreams you know someone beating you
out for a job or an opportunity or something
doesn't mean that you can't still live
a fulfilling life or achieve your dreams
i mean there were jobs that i did not get you
know i interviewed i've only interviewed like
four times maybe for a tv show most of the jobs i
got came from connections that i built over time
the only times that i've interviewed i've never
gotten the job never and that didn't mean that
i couldn't still have a really great career i
mean someone else got that job over me right so
in that sense in the competition i failed there or
whatever someone beat me out but there was another
show for me there were more opportunities for me
you know so i really believe and chelsea handler
talks about this too you know she says like
there's room for everyone can you talk about the
other time that someone said you wouldn't be able
to do something or succeed yeah technically they
didn't say the words but it was implied and it was
something that i'll never forget in high school
i was very involved in drama and chorus so i was
secretary of the drama club i was president of the
chorus that was my life i loved singing i loved
acting not the best at dancing but i wouldn't i
would do what was required but that was my life
you know i lived theater and i did pretty well
you know i was up for the lead several times i
understudied the lead my sophomore year i was
actually up for a lead it was between me
and one other girl my freshman year which
you know was a big deal in the politics of high
school that being a freshman up for a lead and um
i you know i i did well enough to be decent
you know i wasn't the star of our high school
or anything like that i wasn't in that like top
elite group that was like really phenomenal but
i was pretty good i was good enough
to you know get a leading role in a
musical once and and some other big
parts and other opportunities and
i loved theater i i really loved acting i was more
enamored with hollywood than broadway but i really
loved it and like i said i did a summer program
at ucla and it was a summer theater intensive
so i actually went to ucla for acting when i
was still in high school and when we started
applying for colleges i didn't apply to any
acting programs and a lot of my friends did and
i i started discovering my love for graphic design
during that time and so i was feeling pulled
toward graphic design and so that was really what
i was working towards getting into for college
but i was still in the mid you know i'm still in
the midst of theater and i sat down with my the
theater teacher one day and it was just the two of
us in a classroom and i looked at her and i said
you know the reason why i'm not pursuing acting
in college is because i know i'm not good enough
there was like that little girl inside
of me that so badly wanted her to say
you can do it you're good enough like give it a
try if that's really what you want to do go for it
and she didn't and she just sat silent and didn't
say anything and to me that was confirmation you
know of her saying yeah well you're you're not
the star of our program and it's only the stars
that really go on and you know that was so
many years ago and i remember that moment
so clearly still all these years later
it really had an impact on me and
it was one of the reasons you know
why i didn't pursue acting and now
you know i actually believe that everything worked
out how it was supposed to you know i don't still
want to be an actor even when i work with my
actor clients i have no desire i'm not longingly
looking at their careers i was supposed to be a
graphic designer that's that became my true love
um but the lesson that i learned there that i i
wanted to i feel like was one of the reasons i
wanted to become a coach is because i think there
are so many artists that have those moments where
they're maybe told they're not good enough or they
think it themselves and i said in the book that i
wish the teacher saw in me although i really need
to take full responsibility and say i wish i saw
it in myself but i i think i wish the teacher
saw in me that i had all these other qualities
that could potentially lead to success in a
career like hollywood right i was already showing
leadership skills right i was secretary of the
drama club i was i was president over 250 person
chorus have you know worked my way up there and
so i i already had so i was like a self-starter
you know like i had a positive outlook
i was determined and ambitious like i
had so many qualities that could help me
succeed even if i wasn't the absolute star
you know and even if i didn't maybe get into
one of the top desired theater programs like
there's theater programs and countries all
yeah earn schools all around the country um
i don't know i just think that you
know i i own that for myself now
that i wish i saw it in myself but i don't think
at that moment i understood that so much more than
talent was required to succeed and now looking at
like the people who did you know pursue theater
in college from that program in high school i had
only one or two of them is actually doing it so um
and i was still able to create you know pretty
great career for myself in hollywood and break in
when i didn't know anybody and i and i didn't do
that because i was this phenomenal designer i did
it because i had all these other qualities that
helped me break in and we don't know someone's
motives behind why they say something too or don't
say something yeah totally i mean you know and it
could have been her own it doesn't really matter
i i think but you know it was just it was just a
moment for me that i just want to help people not
feel that way because i feel like if there's a
dream in your heart you can pursue it you know
jack canfield has this quote that i always say
where he says you wouldn't be given a dream
unless you had the capacity to fulfill it
and i really believe that i really believe that
you wouldn't be given a dream unless you had the
capacity to fill it doesn't mean right in this
moment when you're 17 years old that you have
all the tools and are able to fulfill it now right
but but it creates potential like it says that the
potential is a hundred percent there is it better
to try to avoid making money as an artist like
should someone not set out to do their art and
also try to make money at it right away i believe
that both can happen and so i go into it believing
this dream will provide for me because i have this
desire of course it's going to financially support
me as well you know it might take time to get to
where you want to be but i have this whole
chapter i know i keep dropping my book and
like name dropping my book but i do have this
whole chapter about you know this idea of being
a starving artist because i think that those two
words you rarely hear them without each other and
i believe that you don't have to be a starving
artist and i also believe that there's nothing
wrong with desiring financial success or with you
know with wanting to make money from your art so
to me it's about i believe that i can create
art that is going to financially support me and
really having that belief from the beginning
most artists don't make money especially
right up front wouldn't it be easier to
accept that most artists accepting that belief
equals determining your fate right so your fate
is a hundred percent dependent upon your belief
so if you believe that most artists don't make
money in the beginning that a hundred percent
will be your fate and what you do when you accept
that belief when you take that belief on you are
now putting yourself into the most people pool
sure most people don't make a ton of money in the
beginning do you have to be most people right and
so can you find an example like i always love to
talk about the example of gilmore girls this is
one of my favorite shows but alexis bledel had
no acting credits on her resume before booking
that title lead role so you know i mean she was
modeling before she had a model in korea there but
but you know breaking into hollywood as an actress
and then you know i i don't know what the going
rates were back then but series regulars now
start at like 25 30 000 an episode depending on
the network right and so you so she technically
went from zero to seven you know several thousand
dollars per week per episode and back then they
were doing 22 24 episode seasons so there's
always going to be an exception to the rule
and i think it's better to focus on the exception
than to focus on the rule i think it's better to
go into it with well i could be that exception
because when you when you accept the rule and you
say oh i'm going to be like most people then
that's exactly what your experience will be
is there a danger in not thinking
that you're part of that pool
is are you saying like is there a danger to think
of yourself in this smaller high achievers pool
yeah oh it's okay i mean what danger i i think
it's like i guess the danger could be like oh
but then you're like putting yourself in this pool
where people make it and what if you don't i think
that um there's no danger in beli believing that
your dreams are possible in a and this is like
the high achiever right like in a really big
way in in a more committed way than most people
i i don't think there's any danger in that and i
think that like the well what if it doesn't happen
i again believe my success is inevitable so to
me there's no specific time frame that it has
to happen and i just know it's going to happen
i don't know when i don't know how i don't know
where but it's going to happen and i have that
belief throughout so there's no well if it doesn't
happen by x that means you're you're in the most
people pool you know i just don't think that way
do you think other people paying you to do
your art inherently makes it worse because
you don't have the same level of freedom to
create the art that's in your heart what if
i believed that the work is in my that the work
that is in my heart is what people will ask for
right so i think it's it's changing the belief
right it's changing the belief about it like oh
i'm gonna have to do something that's not really
in my heart that i don't really want to do because
the clients ask me or whatever right sure that
happens and that has happened on my path you know
like i had day job graphic design jobs that i did
not enjoy but i but they financially supported me
so i could stay in la and keep doing this so
you know i've had that experience but i think
in the bigger picture um if i'm doing work that
doesn't feel good i stop doing it or i don't like
like there is you know i'll be honest i didn't
love working on cop shows because from a graphic
standpoint it's really boring you know it's like
you're designing signs for hospitals and prisons
like like this is basically the only graphics
i do and the rectangles with text and that's
it you know it's not a very creative um you know
genre in terms of graphics and so i did a cop show
i did not enjoy it and then i was like okay i'm
not gonna do this again and then i would turn
down cop shows in the future right so so for me
it's more about like what if i just believe that
the work i want to do is what will be asked of
me can you give us an example of that happening
was there an example where you saw a show that you
wanted to do and you said that's the kind of art i
want to do though that's the color scheme i like
that how do i make that my reality yeah i mean
it wasn't that specific in terms of like color
schemes or certain art it was more just like i
would love to do something that's more creative
where maybe every week the graphics are different
you know where i get to explore more with like
different signage or different props or you know
things that are integral to the story that are
just inherently more interesting and um you know
shortly after that i did book a tv show called
chasing life which was the abc family show that
i said i loved which was a great experience and
i got to do really cool fun different graphics
you know um i feel like my portfolio really
expanded from that show because we got to do
um you know so many different things like we
did a marathon once and i got to do these like
marathon banner graphics but then also you know
the runners tags that they had to wear and and
then i got to do wardrobe you know like there was
a camp and i got to design the sweatshirts that
the counselors were like there was really just
variety um and that was fun for me more so than
you know the cop graphics kind of stuff where
you're just designing rectangles with text so
um yeah and then that that became really fun and
i said okay so this is going to be my new standard
i want to work on a show that feels fun and
creative um and and you know those are the
only things i would say yes to now unless it was
blade runner then that would be cool no i i turned
down sons of anarchy oh you did oh wow no no i i
don't care how big the show is if it's something i
know that i don't think i will enjoy um i won't
do it my happiness is is now more important so
so the so the let the colored leathers on the
back of the motorcycle jackets that just didn't
hit yeah like okay that's like that'd be cool
but my point was that like there you know right
it wasn't even even if it's something even if
a project is like big and well known if i don't
think that i will enjoy doing it then i will
still turn it down sure sure that makes sense
and i just want to add something there because
some people might be going oh well you have
the luxury of turning it down because you're at a
certain point in your career now where you can say
no and you know things are going to come in but
i just want to add on to that is that when i turn
down something that doesn't feel like a good fit
for me i am making room for something better to
come in right so as long as you say yes to things
you don't want to do you now don't even have room
for something new to come in so you know it's not
even necessarily about i'm at a certain place in
my career where now i can say no to things to me
it's really about what do i want to make room for
in my life even if you know the great example is i
talk about all the time people that stay non-union
you know especially actors you know when they're
afraid to join sag because once they join sag
they can no longer do non-union work and
that is scary to them because they only know
non-union work and they feel that non-union is
easier to book than sag work right and so they
like to stay non-union and i say when you
are staying non-union as long as you can
you are staying where you are as long as you can
even though it might take a little longer for the
sag stuff to start flowing in and it might be a
little scarier that doesn't mean that it won't
flow in and as long as you're choosing the other
thing it'll never flow in right so it doesn't
really matter how far you are in your career to be
able to turn things down or to you know to be able
to start making room for what it is you truly
desire it might take some time to bring it in
but you want to at least open yourself up and
make room for the things that you really want
that's a good example right there yeah i know a
lot of people they pay off they don't want to pay
the dues and they keep the eligibility status but
then they just keep keep working yeah good example
what do you teach your clients about money
oh man what don't i teach about no uh money is
such an important topic i think on and really
anyone's journey not even specific to hollywood
i am still in my own learning journey you know of
wealth consciousness and working on my money
mindset but what i like to teach them is
really focus on what is possible and what
sounds exciting instead of focusing on
what doesn't feel good so for example this this
uh example comes up a lot because i remember
my clients telling me about this other teacher
teaching about this when you are focusing on if
you're a writer director actor and you're focusing
on this is how much of my paycheck goes to taxes
and this is how much of my paycheck goes to my
agent or manager and i am left with so little
when you are focusing on i am left with so little
you are going to create more of that in your life
in your career right whatever we focus on expands
so instead of going oh my gosh if i book a
co-star and i only make 800 for the day and then i
guess i start with the thousands easier math to do
in my head you know i only make a thousand dollars
for the day and you know uh 30 of that is going to
taxes 20 is going to my agent a manager and i'm
only going home with like 500 bucks that really
sucks to me that is the most people thinking
right so in terms of money instead of focusing on
how much it sucks when you're left
with little money at the end of the day
instead what if you focus on what if i booked
a recurring role for twenty thousand dollars
and then even though some of it's going to
taxes and my agent and manager i'm still
left with a pretty nice chunk of change right
so instead of focusing on limitations and what
you know feels like your fate is gonna be and
really focus on um you know the the downside
of all of that focus on what's possible focus
on being the one that gets 10 million dollar
paychecks from a movie you know again it's like
the most people pool and the high achiever pool
that high achiever pool people who are making
10 million dollars a movie might be smaller than
most people in the industry but let's focus on
that because that's how you get there you know so
it's so important to really think from an abundant
mindset about what is possible how do you teach
people to stretch that i guess it's a muscle
i get kind of like what i was telling you with
you know my success is inevitable in addition to
suggesting lots of books and resources that i love
that i think are really helpful um because i think
that it's a money mindset is a deep conversation
that needs to happen over time we need to unlearn
a lot of things and relearn new things and
take a look at our own money patterns but just
like with my success inevitable it's like let's
start looking for proof okay i had a client
that booked a 17 000 job right so there's proof
that somebody i worked with you know in
the recent you know past or whatever um
booked a bigger paycheck was able to receive a
bigger paycheck so now your subconscious goes oh
so it's possible oh so it's possible for me to
get that right so again it's like feeding your
subconscious mind proof of what's possible because
proof exists we just choose not to focus on it we
choose to focus on the people that are coming
home with 500 and feeling broke but instead
all this other evidence also exists we're just
saying that it's so rare and that that's not
possible for us or it's like winning the lottery
right and so it's really about looking for that
proof and going okay that is what i want to
focus on and that is what i'm working towards
the gilmore girls example that you gave again
she had been modeling but she'd never had a
speaking role no wow and how long was
i i mean that show is doesn't it like
seven seasons and then they recently did the you
know netflix special that was four episodes long
yeah but there's great like you know i i love the
show so i've watched interviews and things like
that behind the scenes and i read lauren graham's
one of her books and lauren graham talks about how
she played uh alexis blidell's mother as the two
of them for people that don't know gilmore girls
lauren graham talks about she's like if you ever
see a scene where i'm like grabbing alexis arm and
pulling her close to me she's like i was pulling
her on her mark because she was so new that she
you know she didn't in the beginning you know
she didn't necessarily know all those things like
oh you need to stand on your mark and you know
things that a seasoned actor would know and so
even without all that that's how new she was even
without all that knowledge and all that experience
she's still booked the title one of the title
roles series regular like seven seasons wow see
and that's possible when we focus on that instead
of you know the actor who books one co-star a
year and really struggles right it's like both
evidence exists which one do we want to focus on
how does money change an artist i
don't think money changes anybody
i think again it's it's all internal
so whatever it looks like money changed
was already there inside right so sometimes they
say you know fame is like holding up a magnifying
glass to what's already there you know like
for example i worked on a show i won't mention
names but i worked on a show where one of the
lead actresses was not a very nice person and
i found out that people who knew her before she
was famous said that she was like that then you
know she wasn't a nice person that it's like it's
like holding up a magnifying glass so i don't
think that money i don't think any external thing
changes us you know i think that only you know i
mean events and things like that i guess can shift
our perception or our feelings our beliefs but i
don't think like a tangible thing like money which
is just like a value exchange i don't think that
necessarily changes people i think again it's
like a magnifying glass to what's already there
so a lot of times people will feel when i have x
amount of money all my money problems will go away
but having more money doesn't change your spending
habits it doesn't change your saving habits or
what you do with your money how you treat your
money you are the person that does that it might
inspire you to change your habits you know
it might inspire you to do things differently
but i don't think money actually changes people
from the people you've worked with how does their
outward success change the people
around them oh good question
i cuz i love that like to me that it makes me so
happy to help i say spread the light like i want
to spread the light in hollywood you know the
people that i work with helping them feel good
and feel inspired again will then help people
around them feel inspired so again i think it's
more about the internal changes than the external
things that they book the projects that they book
um i think that you know like um one of my
clients was saying that her mom said oh you
know you're you're so upbeat recently you know
you're so positive and happy and she was like yes
you know i'm a month working with erica um
so i think that it's more the internal shift
that impacts people around them in a positive
way but you know i guess the things that they
the projects that they might book or the external
things um can kind of i guess with the internal
shifts also help impact people but you know what
i'm seeing and what i and what i really hope is
that it impacts people for the better where it
inspires other people to go after their dreams
and it shows other people what's possible you know
when i first started out 13 almost 13 years ago
i read jack camfield's success principles it's my
very first self-help book i ever read and i was
like this is the greatest thing ever i loved it
so much and i think it really helped me break in
to hollywood so quickly and one of the tactics
that he talked about was writing your goals on
an index card and so i would do that for
every goal for years i don't do it anymore
um because my my belief around that has
shifted a little bit but like my dad
started writing his goals down on index cards
i was like that is so cool you know i think
you know there's something so incredible
about inspiring others to go after their
dreams or to believe in more you know believe
in more possibility for themselves by seeing
people they know or love do it but what if that
doesn't happen what if it doesn't inspire others
what if it takes another turn what do you
mean what if somehow they can't handle that
have you seen that in like the person who who's
succeeding or the person that's watching them
the person that's succeeding what if
some of the individuals around them
that threatens them have you worked with your
clients on that and and how do they internalize
that so they're feeling threatened by
their success or the dynamics changed
power structures change and so it it upsets the
apple cart yeah i mean that absolutely does happen
and i've coached many clients through that i
think especially with friends um and i think that
you know you can't control somebody else's
journey right so so like my client can't control
their friend getting on board and being excited
and being inspired or feeling threatened or
feeling you know not good about it or whatever
right we can't control somebody else's journey
they're on their own path and so it's not up
to us how they feel and and one of the things
that i work with my clients a lot is because a
lot of times when we're doing the mindset it's
really the internal shifts that that impact their
relationships the most and and a lot of times
i say that when you start changing and growing
what you used to tolerate becomes less tolerable
so the people that maybe aren't getting on
board maybe were never meant to get on board
with them right and maybe it was something they
were tolerating before but it's like they can't
even tolerate anymore they don't want to be
around them right so i think that you know it's
important that we surround ourselves with people
who support us and who want us to win and are you
know and excited for us and if people are feeling
you know negative nancy's they're feeling down
um that's okay you know they're on their own path
but the more we surround ourselves with people
like that the more time we spend with them the
more it can start to drag us down if we're not
incredibly strong about our own energy and thought
process so i never think it's about like oh you
need to break up with this friend you know i don't
think it's necessarily about cutting people out of
your life but just being more um present and and
aware of the kinds of conversations you have with
them and and the things that they say and then
how it impacts how you feel when you've had a
client reach tremendous success what were some of
the surprises that they weren't ready to handle
well i work with i've worked with a lot of
new people so tremendous success i i don't
know if you know that's that's all relative and i
don't know if i've like i don't know if i've ever
coached somebody that that achieved something so
incredible that they weren't ready for because i
think that the work that we do gets them ready for
it um and that's always what it's about like it's
all again it's always the internal thing you
know how do you feel about what is happening
and do you have support around you you know that's
like why some of my clients end up staying into
like i have a membership where it's just a couple
coaching calls a month in a group setting so that
they can keep up with the you know the work to
keep up with that belief system keep up with that
mindset work so that as they do achieve things
they have the support system to to help them you
know handle anything that comes their way so so
some of this has never come as a surprise to them
it's they've taken these steps and they were ready
emotionally yeah nothing's ever a surprise i mean
like because i train them to expect success and
i don't even i shouldn't even say i train them i
don't want to take responsibility they they shift
their belief system to believe that their success
is coming so nothing it's never a surprise it's
exciting and they're really happy about it and you
know it's funny like even small things one of my
clients um texted me the other day in our in her
session she she moved home during the pandemic and
is going to move back to l.a soon and she was like
you know when do i move like i'm looking at places
i don't know when the timing is right and i said
when you find a place that you love that feels
really good and i was like watch i bet this
week you'll find a place now that we have this
conversation and she texted me the next day and
was like you won't believe one of those apartments
just became available that i was interested in
so there's never it's never a surprise it's
expected i mean it's it's surprised in the way
of like wow this really did come true this really
did happen and there's excitement around that but
never a surprise so expect success okay i like
that and do you think with the every people pool
it's not expected correct i'm hoping yeah
correct i'm fingers crossed okay ask anyone
ask ask most people you know ask them what
they believe about about their success and
or about the next booking or the next job or
whatever and yeah most people do not expect it
they expect failure or they expect it to take
a long time or they expect struggle erica would
you mind reading a page or two from your book
i just so happen to have it on my lap right
okay i would be happy to like i'm like a teacher
this is chapter 16 it's called own your power okay
your dream comes from the most powerful
place you it's born from divine inspiration
one of the most powerful forces in the
universe this calling becomes a burning desire
one that gives you ambition perseverance drive and
even compassion in a way you've never felt before
it helps form the most powerful
version of you there ever was
and yet the moment it becomes an
impossible feat you have to achieve
the power is immediately stripped away it's
your superpower and kryptonite all in one
but the stripping of your
power is really an illusion
it's a choice to give it away and
a choice you don't have to make
instead of feeling at the mercy of others to make
your dream come true you can take your power back
by realizing as abraham hicks says they are
all just pawns in the law of attraction game
you get to control so much more than you think
you get to control your energy your vibration
your beliefs your strategy your actions your
risks and asks and the most important of them
all you get to create your reality all of those
things combined with the belief in abundance and
limitless opportunities leads to a world where it
doesn't matter if someone says yes or no to you
the dream is happening no matter what i think one
of my superpowers is reminding people how powerful
they really are that shift in energy can be all
it takes to manifest exciting new opportunities
because how you show up to the world
is how the world will show up for you
whatever you believe will be reflected back
to you if you feel powerless in your dream
pursuit you will have experiences that
confirm those feelings and vice versa
ps owning your power is so much more
fun so let's choose that shall we
let me help you by busting the power myths that
your subconscious is fighting for here is one of
the power myths gatekeepers gatekeepers are like
the bouncers of the club deciding who gets in
it feels like they have all the power and
artists are at the mercy of their decision
actors are at the mercy of casting directors
authors are at the mercy of publishers
startups are at the mercy of investors it feels
like these gatekeepers are in charge of our fate
and we have no control over what they say access
to our dreams is in their hands so how are we
supposed to feel powerful in those moments
we hold none of the power in those decisions
clap that's me waking you up from the hypnotic
spell you're under time for the powerful truth
powerful truth these gatekeepers do not determine
your fate only you can do that pillar number seven
says that your success is inevitable which
means your fate has already been decided
any single gatekeeper or any single opportunity
will not break your chances of succeeding
it's already been decided your success is a
done deal who cares what the gatekeeper says
your person is coming your opportunity
is coming because it's inevitable
and if that's the case what if these gatekeepers
were in fact allies what if they were friends
what if they were your support
system your cheer squad
what if the universe always placed
people on your path to help you
and what if that help didn't always come in
the pretty package you want a no could be just
as much a gift as a yes when jack canfield's
book was turned down 144 times by publishers
what if that was all a gift because the publisher
he was meant to work with happened to be the 145th
what if it's all working out perfectly
we tend to put gatekeepers on pedestals
because we think they hold the power but
you hold the power take them down from
that pedestal they are just people
they are pawns in your game and this
game is in the highest good of everyone
you know the value you bring you know you
were meant to do this so it can't not work out
if this gatekeeper doesn't let you in it
says nothing about your potential it says
nothing about your future or your ability to
succeed it just wasn't a match but i promise you
your people are out there keep going
because they're looking for you too
excellent that's just two pages
why did you choose that passage
well one because i think that it's something
a lot of people struggle with i think that so
many filmmakers feel powerless in this industry
and they are constantly searching for ways to
feel powerful that's why a lot of people do their
own work you know film their own projects because
they want to feel in control and they feel
like everything's out of control so i wanted
to read that to address that you know exact thing
i think that there's so many ways that we can feel
you know be in our own power without it even
having to be something as literal as filming your
own content um and also because so many people
have read the beginning of the book the first
chapter and i think a lot of what we talked about
today was stories from the first couple chapters
and so i wanted to share something from the
back of the book the third section um that to me
feels like this is how a high achiever thinks you
know a high achiever doesn't feel at the mercy of
gatekeepers they feel that they have the power to
create whatever they want and if something doesn't
work out or doesn't happen the way they wanted it
to that's okay it doesn't mean that it it's not
still going to happen and how did you feel writing
that chapter did it did were you sort of empowered
i mean as you're writing it were you almost
transformed into another world yeah i mean
everything i wrote i need to hear over and
over again you know i read my own book a lot
and i'm not trying to say that in like a
super arrogant way but in a way of like i
needed to hear this again today you know um yeah
i really feel like i i mean so much of the book
came from working with my clients and the work
that we've done over several years now um but
i do feel like i sort of i don't want to say
channeled you know but i just feel like it
it came from a place like i i felt like this was
this idea to write this book was divinely sent
to me like i just i just got the idea it wasn't
something i strategize i didn't strategize and say
oh i should write a book i was like i just felt
this feeling of like you ha like you have to get
this message out to help people you know and then
when covent hit not to be super morbid i was like
i have to get this message out before i die what
if i get coveted and die like i was really feeling
like i need to finish this book i told my mom
where like my book files were on my computer
i was just a little fearful during you know
like during this pandemic um but yeah i just
i don't know i just i really want more people
to to hear this message and hopefully it will
help transform you know their careers when you
tell your clients this message are they resistant
at first oh yeah i mean yes and no and and myself
as well you know i i share this story with my
clients a lot when i was first starting out you
know really embracing some of this for myself i
was working with a life coach and we were talking
about money abundance in terms of money and
i was really struggling financially that month
and i said i'm so broke i'm so broke i really
need a haircut i can't afford a haircut i can't
afford anything she said erica you are an abundant
person you are so abundant you have access to
money all around you and i said do you want to
look at my bank account i have hardly any money
in it and i went back and forth with her arguing
about how broke i was no you don't understand
you need to hear me i am broke i am struggling
i need to be heard and my poor coach
she was so patient and kind with me
you know because i had so much resistance and now
of course looking back i share that story because
when i look back now i can see like i was really
fighting for my limitations i was fighting to stay
where i was i wasn't listening to her when she
was you know like it's like if i listen to her
like i there i could have been open to
solutions like with the fedex logo right
there could have been solutions in front of me
that i didn't see because i didn't want to see
them i wanted to instead prove how broke i was so
i myself have been resistant and i've definitely
had clients be resistant especially in terms
of not not really necessarily the belief but
the action that it should then lead to so for
example like one time i worked with a client who
i was like you need to change your day job because
her day job had her traveling a lot and she would
travel for like at least one week every month
so she was out of town a lot and i was like you
want to audition and this is pretty pandemic you
know nothing with self-doubt you want to audition
and you know get representation and audition and
books work you're not even here to do it this day
job i understand that it's supporting you but you
need a different day job that's going to support
what you're actually trying to do because
right now it's blocking you and it took her
i think like six weeks i mean it took her weeks
you know because that's a scary thing you know
that's definitely a risk but you know working
through the mindset of it of like believing that
your success is inevitable if you take this risk a
you you start to believe of course there's another
day job out there for me of course i can believe
that that's possible that i can be financially
supported in a day job that also gives me time
to audition you know and stay in la at least
and not be traveling right it's like you have to
start to believe that things can work out for you
even with these little things of i have to believe
not only that my success is inevitable but that i
can find a different day job i have to believe
that i can be financially supported you know
yeah so we worked through you know shifting
her beliefs and eventually she came around
changed her day job got an agent right away booked
her first co-star booked a lead in a tv movie
you know so so things really shifted for her but
you know it's okay to have resist it's okay that
it takes time i think as long as you're open to
doing the work it doesn't have to happen overnight
but if you're if you're open to doing that work i
think then that's that's where the benefit will be
when you had the down period after you had
moved out here got this great job and then
the recession hit or was already in motion
and i believe then the show was canceled
were you fighting for your limitations oh yeah
oh yes um yes i really was and again it goes back
to you know i had those like blinders on of only
seeing the problem and not allowing myself to
open up to solutions i didn't do nothing like i
you know i'm an ambitious person and i i tried
you know i put myself out there i think i cold
emailed a bunch of you i i try to get another
job so it's not like i didn't do anything but
i had those blinders on and i was definitely like
you know it's like if my mom suggested like oh you
should you could go for a drive or go down to the
ocean no mom i can't do that that means i have to
put gas in the car and i can't afford gas you know
so it was like i was constantly focused on the
problem um and fighting to stay there essentially
you know my mom was like trying to tell me all
these things that could potentially help me
and it took me a long time to get to a place
where i stopped fighting for my limitations and i
finally opened myself up to help at what point in
your career did you go without work for was it a
year okay what happened yeah that was in 2009 and
that contact that one connection that i
had made helped me get that first show
but i didn't have like a huge rolodex
of people that i knew in the industry so
it was really challenging to book another job
because you know as from a graphic designer
standpoint you really need to know people you
know one once you get into the union there
is an availability list that you can put
yourself on and you can get some jobs from
your name being on the availability list
but people are only going to that list
until they've you know they've gone through
they've exhausted their list of people they know
so it's so much about who you know and i
just didn't know enough people yet you know
my pool was so small so um i i had you know it
was like the worst year of my life because it
was also the recession and so i couldn't even get
a waitressing job like i remember this one day
where i saw craigslist posting for a waitress
interview a server interview and i got my car
right away and drove right over and there were
already like 10 people in line and they were
only taking one person so it that was really
challenging too and like i really you know
even now i try to get better but i tend to
tie myself worth to how much money i have
and so when i like couldn't even make a living
as like getting a server job or something like
that or any kind of side job um it and and this
was also before uber and lyft existed you know i
couldn't drive for instacart i couldn't i couldn't
do those things it couldn't be a postmates person
um and so that was really hard for me too so
not only like struggling to find the work but
then tie my worth to that and and feeling so
unworthy of success or anything that i wanted
that was really hard how well do you remember
the depression that you faced oh gosh i very
well because i still experience it all the time
like i think i'm prone to depression i call it
situational depression because it usually comes
from a situation so something happens um to cause
me to be depressed i don't normally feel it just
to feel it with no trigger um so i recall it very
well because i felt it again many times since
then um but it was just a really pivotal time
in my life like i remember it so well so well i
can really connect you know to those feelings and
you know what i tried to do you know just
all the things that i did and even though
it was almost 13 years ago at this point 12
years ago i i still remember it very clearly
that was a really rough time for a lot of
people yes it was and i mean thank god i
didn't have kids or didn't have a home you
know so many people lost their homes and
you know much worse than you
know fortunately i was able to
stay afloat and i you know i had two roommates
at the time and so i was able to still stay in
la which is amazing it could have been much worse
but yeah it was a tough time how are you able to
book a job at the end of all that i asked for
help it was so hard i my cousin told me a story
um it's a short story i can tell it quickly
and people probably heard it before i forget
all the details but essentially there was
a man in his house and it started raining
and as the rain came down it didn't stop and it
started to flood and he was like oh my gosh how
am i gonna be okay and he just kept praying to god
god save me i will be okay please help me god and
the flood kept growing and the rain was getting
worse and so he goes to the upstairs in his house
so he can get to the next level because it's
starting to come into his house and he sees um
someone in their truck drives by and they're like
hey man we can help you come jump in the truck and
he was like no god will save me i'm going to
go upstairs to this upper level i will be fine
and then the rain keeps coming and the flood
is rising and someone in a boat passes by
and they're like hey jump in the boat we'll help
you we'll save you they see him in this window
you know jump out of your win and he's like
no i'll be okay i'm praying god will save me
and then finally it becomes like unbearable and
he has to literally climb to the roof of his house
and a helicopter comes and flies over and
drops a ladder and says you know we grab
the ladder we can save you i said no god will
save me i prayed and i know god will save me
and the water rose so much that he couldn't
go anywhere and he ended up drowning
and died and he goes to heaven and he's like
god what the heck i prayed for you to save me
why didn't you save me and god said i sent you a
truck i sent you a boat i sent you a helicopter
and when my cousin told me that story
it really helped me see that like if
you're drowning it's okay to ask for
help you know i felt very ashamed of where
i was you know in my life and how much i was
struggling because again i really tied
it to my self-worth and i just thought
you know i'm not a good enough human being i
don't deserve this and so i don't even deserve
somebody's help you know and i would
ghost people's texts you know i just
wouldn't even respond to friends texts or calls
because i was so ashamed i was so embarrassed
you know if they say how are you what's
going on and i would say nothing nine
months later and still nothing is going on i was
so ashamed so after my cousin told me that story
i was like okay and so i reached out to one of
the girls that i had become friendly with from
the first show and i told her look i really need a
job if you know of anyone looking because she was
the same age as me but she had already been in the
industry longer and she knew a lot of people and
so she had found other work i said i really need a
job if you hear of anything could you let me know
and she heard of something and
she recommended me and it was glee
and they called me and they called me a
week after i finally got a waitressing job
a week after and i was like you have no idea how
much i want to come work for you but it was to
fill in for somebody for just a couple days and
i was like you have no idea how badly i want to
say yes to you but i just spent like eight or
nine months with no job and i just got this
waitressing job a week ago i don't think i can
quit this for just a couple days work even though
i really want to and so i said like if something
else comes up longer term please please call me
and a month later they did and they called me and
they said now we need someone to fill in for the
rest of the season and i gave my notice after a
month of waitressing and i went and worked on glee
wow because that goes back to that energy shift
and so here you had something you finally got a
waitressing job after you know racing down to an
open call for one and then then this other one
opened up so that goes back to what you're talking
about earlier definitely i mean even just getting
the waitressing job it filled me up so much you
know and not even just self-worth and feeling like
wow okay i finally have some money coming in i
can survive and i have a job but also being around
other people you know because i was so afraid
to spend money that i wouldn't leave my room
i would stay in my room in my apartment like all
day every day i was afraid to leave because it
would cost me money to leave and i just i wasn't
around people and so that i think also helped to
be around people and you know waitressing your
your hustling and walking fast and suddenly so
i was getting exercise again and moving my
body you know all of these things that were
beneficial that i think really shifted my energy
than to be open for a tv show very interesting
wow what a story so so when
you got the waitressing job
how did that feel because i realized that wasn't
your ultimate destination no it wasn't but i was
elated you know i just needed something i hadn't
had any work in so long i i was so so happy and so
grateful to get that weight choosing job yes wow
do you ever go back to that restaurant well then
know now you probably can't because it's just
takeout if it's still around right well so that
so it's funny because so it's it's on the block
near where i live so i could walk there and i
felt so guilty about like leaving after just
a month and i could tell the manager was not
happy with me that on glee i was an assistant
and i was in charge of getting lunch every day
so i would always say hey we should go to this
restaurant and so i gave them business and we
would order from the whole office and order
lunch there and i would go there and pick it
up because i wanted to still give them business
you know because i felt so bad about leaving
um and so and i and that restaurant was
amazing food so good but it doesn't exist
anymore and another restaurant is in its place
now that's also a very good restaurant and i go
there when it's open yes that's a great story
and and and even the staff like the people in
the kitchen and the other servers like some of
them i still talk to you to this day some of
them went to the restaurant next door and i always
say hi i get so excited to see them and it's nice
do you believe in visualization
yes how does it work
well it works however you want
it to work but i think that
so i'm really fascinated by the science behind
it i just think it's so fascinating and so dr
joe dispenza teaches a lot of the science behind
it i'm so fascinated so he talks about he gave
this really good example of a an experiment that
they did i don't know if he conducted or someone
else did a long time ago where they monitored the
brain of somebody rehearsing practicing the piano
and it was for a certain amount of hours
a couple days a week or something and they
literally would get brain scans or you
know i don't know the scientific term
but they studied their brain um to see what
happens like what part of the brain lights up
you know what happens in your brain when you're
rehearsing playing the piano and then they did
the same thing but asked him to just rehearse it
in his mind just visualize yourself rehearsing
for the same amount of time so if it was three
hours spend three hours rehearsing playing the
piano not actually touching a piano and what they
found was the exact same part of the brain lit up
and what this was really showing them is that your
brain doesn't really know the difference between
something imagined or visualized and something
real that's right in front of you and they talk
about when you visualize what you want happening
and you you close your eyes and you really see it
in detail and you play it out like a movie in
your mind you're actually impacting the quantum
field i mean this is like quantum physics and it's
getting a little sciency but you're actually like
impacting the quantum field around you and it
creates possibility like it create like now
now that you envisioned it it exists in real life
somewhere and he talks about he does a much better
job explaining because i'm an art brain not a
science brain and so i kind of summarized the
science that he shared but the way that i remember
it but he said that you know for example in the
morning when you wake up if you have a thought i
have to go to the bathroom right when you wake up
and then your body goes to the bathroom so
your body physically follows the thought
so when you visualize you know play out this movie
in your mind of you booking a project or you know
getting anything that you want your body then
will follow the thought and it will lead you to
actions and things to do and you know
connections people to talk to whatever
um to to follow that thought because your brain
thinks it's real doesn't know the difference
and and joe talks about dr joe talks about
um and i don't really do this enough i'm a
very visual person so it's super easy for
me to visualize and i i can kind of do it
without even having to go into a deep meditation
like i can just i can connect to it so easily
because i'm such a visual person but dr joe
talks about like for this to work really well
it's best if you can do this in a meditative
state so if you can just close your eyes
and visualize whatever it is that you want
to visualize let's say like i do this great
meditation visualization my clients were like i
might walk them through a day of them going to set
you know booking you know on a
project that they love you know
they get up and they get in their car and we
play out the whole day you drive to paramount
studios you get to your trailer you sit in the
hair and make you know literally all the details
of it and like what's around you and um dr joe
talks about like incorporating your five senses
you know you know sense of like how does it smell
you know what what are you touching what do you so
to really um you know make it come to life in your
mind and so he says that if you can get to a place
in your meditative state and every time i talk
about this i'm like erica you need to do this more
because this is so great if you can get to a place
in your meditative state where you're visualizing
and you forget about you're
no longer connected to time
your body or your environment meaning you're just
so into this visualization that you have no idea
five minutes past or 30 minutes past right
so you're not like super aware of time
you are not fidgeting you know or touching your
body so like you're just so into it that you're
not even aware of your body or itchy or you know
whatever we do when we're wiggling in a in a
meditation and then your environment like you're
not thinking about the room that you're sitting in
when you can get to a place where you're not
no longer aware of those three things that's
like the magic space where the visualization
comes to life and really kind of creates in this
quantum field so i think visualization is
just such an amazing tool for us to use like
one it just gets you excited you know i think
it's just good to help get you in the energy
which i can even do just talking about the
specifics of my dream i get excited you know
if anyone asks me about like the house i want
to buy i will go on forever and i get so excited
and i can tell you all the details that's like
brings me that energy of the visualization um
but so i think it's good for that sense and like
it gets you excited and it gets you connected
to the possibility which then will lead to
ideas or actions or bigger risks you know
any of the thing that good energy will lead to um
and then also you're from a scientific perspective
you know you're essentially creating this
possibility in the quantum field and now you're
expecting it to happen and so you're doing all
the things you would do if you knew it was coming
do you have any examples of how this creative
visualization has helped some of your clients
so one of the things that i have my clients do in
addition to visualizing is to write it out and so
i have what they do we call it a clear intentions
list and so they write like a list of what their
intentions are what they want to create and so
i mean this happens all the time they get the
agent or manager that matches everything on their
list you know they create things all the time and
one of my clients actually the other day had
posted in the facebook group that she recently
got a new agent that feels really great it's
a great relationship they're bringing her high
quality auditions they they understand each
other it seems like they really support her
dream you know like all these dreamy things that
people want from a rep that they often don't get
and she said i i because i told her i'm like
man i wish we could go back to your two-year
ago self and tell that version of you like that
you got this great rep and you're having this
wonderful experience and she's like i know she
said like i remember one of your other clients
having it happen to her a year ago and feeling
like so excited for her and seeing that it was
possible and really wanting that for myself
and and then it happened for her so um
so not so it's not necessarily that they're
going through the whole like meditation
visualization although i think a lot of my clients
are doing that naturally um but really visualizing
in any kind of sense even outside of meditation
what it is they want and then having it happen
do you ever see people who are unable
to make positive changes in their life
yeah yeah i do i think you know no judgment
again i think everyone's on their own
path and actually this is something that i
had to work on as a coach to not take that on
for myself and beat myself up about it
like i didn't do a good enough job i didn't
i you know i couldn't i couldn't change them i
you know my work couldn't um help them change
you know i've struggled with that in the past
um and really had to learn like i give them the
tools but it's up to them what they do with it
you know i can't make anybody do anything so um
i've definitely seen that happen but i do think
that everyone's on their own path and i think that
people come around when they when they come around
and when they when they need to when it's right
for them um you know tony robbins talks about
how everyone moves towards pain or pleasure so
a lot of times he says you know people don't
change until the pain becomes too great
and that's been my experience 100 as well you know
it's like like i remember when i was working on a
show full time and starting my coaching business
and i really got to the point where i needed
to leave the show in order for my business to
take off if that's what i wanted like there was
only so much i could do with my business
working on a tv show full time especially
tv hours you know working 8 10 hour day or 10
12 hour days um i knew i had to leave the job
but it took me a while to make that you know to
actually make that leap you know as ambitious and
driven as i am i have my own moments of resistance
and i it took me time and it wasn't until the pain
became too great where i said what am i doing i
can't stay here like i have to get out you know
something happened at work it wasn't even a big
thing but it was something that gave me reason
to leave and it wasn't until the pain became too
great that i actually made the change um and so
yeah so tony says that we're moving towards pain
or towards pleasure where like there's something
you want and so you make a decision based on that
because you really want it so i think that um
when people you know aren't aren't
making positive changes in their life
maybe the pain just hasn't become too great yet
you know and maybe that moment will happen for
them in the future what goes through your mind
when someone tells you you can't do something
i will say that there's like there's still a
little teeny part of me that like the answer's
first in my mind and says oh yeah they're right
like even with all the work i do there's still
like this teeny tiny part but i i quiet very
quickly and um i just don't accept that for myself
i and because because there's always going to
be proof that that's not true for everybody or
everything you know that's why i say to look for
absolutes when they're saying words like always or
never that'll never work or you can't do that you
know but there's always going to be an exception
to that right so so i can't i can't take that on
as my own and even if it even if no proof existed
and it was something new that i was trying to do
i still have to believe that it's possible i still
have to get behind that um regardless so usually
if somebody tells me that they're either someone
that i'm not going to work with moving forward
or um you know i might try to educate them on my
philosophy you know how i view things but you know
in the in the industry i i still do hear it a lot
yeah can you talk about
limiting beliefs and how we
live someone else's reality this is where i
want to talk about realistic i think that um
what somebody else deems as realistic is
based upon their belief system and they might
be limited in that scope you know they might
have a limiting belief about what is realistic
and the way that our subconscious
mind works is that if we believe them
that means we're deciding that what they're saying
is true then it gets stored in a subconscious
but if we don't believe them then it
doesn't get stored in our subconscious
and so we have to get more aware and vigilant
about what we allow into our subconscious because
if we don't we will end up living somebody else's
version of what they think is realistic you know
based on their limiting beliefs so for example
you know as an entrepreneur myself starting a
business and wanting to own a home and you know
in the hills or by the ocean that's going to
be a multi-million dollar home so if i want
to you know buy a multi-million dollar home
i have to believe that it's realistic for that to
happen i have to believe that it's realistic for
me to buy a multi-million dollar home and the
way that i do that is by looking for proof and
for ways of how to make that tangibly happen like
if i can learn more about what it takes to own a
multi-million dollar home what does my income
need to be you know i spoke to realtors i spoke
to lenders i you know i learned about the process
of you know how much would i put down you know
people that are buying at that level are they
paying cash you know i really had to learn all of
these things and the more i learned it the more it
becomes more realistic because i understand what
it takes right so as i have grown as a business
owner as an entrepreneur i started to know people
you know i started to expand my friend base of
other entrepreneurs who are further along than me
financially right so for example one of my friends
last year just hit her first million dollar a year
so a million dollars in a year that's like 83
000 a month right now most people would say 83
000 a month that's not realistic right some people
aren't even making that per year and so we decide
that that isn't realistic but to my friend who has
done it it's totally realistic to her she did it
so her reality is not the same of somebody else's
reality because she believe you know she believes
in a different definition of what is realistic
and if we look at it it's totally realistic for
her to make 83 000 a month it's also totally
realistic for her to incrementally grow every
year and make more than that you know it is not
that far off for her to make a hundred thousand
dollars a month her one of her mentors has made
up to four hundred thousand dollars a month
again it sounds like something that's not
realistic right and you could say oh well she
got lucky or she won the lottery no they're just
entrepreneurs that learned how to build a business
and and actually jack canfield says in that book
the success principles that a millionaire is made
every four minutes i believe in the united states
so it's much more common than we realize but in
our mind tells us it's not realistic so if i
want to be a millionaire or if i want to own
a multi-million dollar home and that means that i
need to have an income you know past a million i
can't take on somebody else's belief that says i
can't do that i can't listen to someone that says
erica that's not really realistic right i can't
take that on because if i do it'll never happen
i'll never get that house so instead i have to
surround myself with people like my friend who
who's already now hitting a million dollars a
year and seeing how she's doing it and learning
from her and going oh okay totally realistic
so i'm deciding that what i want even though
it might sound crazy to other people is actually
really realistic to me you know and so i i have
to decide that for myself and i i can't base
my belief on what someone else's belief is
ah
that sounds like a nice that sounds really
nice how can an artist ruin their own career
because they're living someone else's
fear-based reality well i mean with my example
of the house if i take on someone else's
limiting belief that this is impossible
i i ruined the dream by not even if i don't
even believe it could happen i'm not gonna
learn how to grow my income i'm not gonna speak
to a lender and learn what a lender is going to
need from me as an entrepreneur who doesn't bring
home w-2s every day every week you know like all
of that research that i've done i wouldn't
do that research if i take on their beliefs
so you know i don't know if ruin is the word that
i would use that they're ruining their career
but i think that they're you're always going to
get what you believe so if you take on somebody
else's belief that this can't happen or you can't
have that that's exactly what you will get so um
it'll i guess ruin you know any chances
of having the thing that you desire if
you're not believing that you can have it how do
we get in tune with our own reality in tune with
your own reality meaning in tune with the reality
you want to create like whatever you want to be
realistic for yourself that's true because i guess
we could get in tune with our own reality that's
negative like basically you never want to get in
tune with your reality like your reality is not
having what you want right like like right now in
my reality i don't have the house so i don't want
to get in tune with that reality i want to get in
tune with the reality in which i have the house
so i mean abraham hicks talks about this a lot
but it's really about like stop focusing on what
you don't have you know abraham says that every
subject is really two subjects the having it and
then not having it so if you want to book a show
you're either focused on the fact that you haven't
booked it yet and don't have it or you're focused
on the fact that you're going to have it right
and so one of those is the dominant thought
there and so you don't want to focus on the
reality that you don't have it you want to focus
on the reality you're creating in the future
in the near future so you really want to get in
tune with the reality that you want to create
you know from a law of attraction standpoint
and you know talk in terms of like
manifesting whatever is in your life right
now you have created you have manifested
so everything you have now is based on things
you've done in the past and so the same for
the future things that you want is going to
be based on what you're doing right now so
what you're doing right now oh it's talking about
getting in alignment with the thing that you want
what do we do now to manifest that thing in the
future we get aligned with it meaning we believe
that we're going to have it you know we stop
focusing on lack stop focusing on what we don't
have and we just get excited about it we visualize
we focus on how it's going to feel it's really
about the feeling so when when i have this job i'm
going to feel really excited and really confident
and really proud okay well can i experience those
emotions right now totally you don't need to book
a job to feel excited you can get excited right
you can create that emotion for yourself so it's
about like how can i just focus on feeling excited
and confident and proud right and that is going to
call this in as opposed to if i got in tune with
my current reality where i don't have the job
i might feel sad i might feel frustrated i might
feel not worthy right and all of those things and
and when we focus on those feelings and by the
way this is not to say that it's bad to feel
those feelings like i always tell my clients it's
healthy and okay to feel whatever comes up for you
it's just about can we shorten the time in which
we don't feel good and shift into feeling better
so um it's getting aligned with those feelings
and belief in what's coming and expecting it
how does someone take action toward their
goals when they can barely get out of bed
in the morning they don't i think the action that
they work on is getting out of bed in the morning
you know we can sometimes feel overwhelmed with
all of the things we need to do or want to do but
if you're feeling that way if you're feeling
like i can't get out of bed in the morning
you really just want to focus on the task at hand
which is like you know abraham talks about um
you don't have to jump the emotional scale so
if you're feeling really low you don't have to
try to jump to feeling amazing and going for your
dreams doing all your goals you know doing all the
actions for your goals it's about incremental
increases like could i just feel a little bit
better can i somehow focus on getting myself
better so i feel good enough to get out of bed
can i then maybe take a shower or could i maybe
do some exercise to get my heart rate going and
build those endorphins and just take care of
myself you know can i can i climb that ladder
so that from here then you can feel a little
better in here and then here right and you you're
incrementally climbing so that when you get to a
place then when you can finally start to feel good
then you can focus on going for your goals
but i think that you know our mental health
is so much more important than any goal and
so it's so important i always tell my clients
too like your alignment your energy should be
your priority above all you know so if you are
feeling really rejected one day and you're feeling
really down don't go email 10 more agents because
you don't feel good you know wait until you feel
better work on make your energy the priority
work on what can i do to make myself feel better
to shift my energy that has to be my priority
then i'll go take those actions because you really
want to take the action from a place where you
feel good so that you get that reflected back to
you plus when you're feeling good you'll be led to
better ideas you know when you're when you can't
even get out of bed you're not going to have that
amazing idea you know to take some new risk and
going back to your job scenario which is a great
example you finally got this one job which was
more of a survival job and it really helped you
yes just get out of your own mindset all this
stuff and then that's when the re the job that
you really wanted came calling totally totally and
again that's why i say like i'm so grateful for
that waitressing job you know really helped shift
my energy and get me out of feeling depressed and
yeah that did really good things for me yeah
what do you consider the impossible dream well
the title of my book has that word in quotes in
the subtitle because i don't think that anything's
impossible i really don't and i i i know that
sounds cheesy oh nothing's impossible but
you can't think that anything you want is
impossible or else you'll never go for it
in the manner that it's going to require
so i don't think anything's impossible i
think other people might tell you that they
think it's impossible you know there might
be data or evidence that suggests it might be
challenging but any obstacle or any challenge
to me that's that's not enough information
to say oh that's too impossible i shouldn't
do it i shouldn't even try so yeah i don't
i don't believe that anything is impossible
how would you handle if one of your clients was
giving up on their quote unquote hollywood dream
and you feel like maybe that's the right
decision for them i've never felt that way
ever i would never feel that way to again though
it's not a it's not my decision it's not up to me
i you know i would never decide if someone should
go for it or not or if someone should quit or not
that has to come from them alone and so i would
just encourage them to get in touch with their
true desires and their true feelings to help them
figure out what's the right move for them you know
i don't think there's anything wrong with someone
saying i want to do something else now instead
like that's okay too i mean look at me i worked in
television for all these years and then i was like
i want to coach i want to help other people so
you know our dreams change sometimes but i would
never be the one to tell someone that they should
quit or they shouldn't do this have you ever seen
it where someone comes to you and they say you
know i'm not getting to x y and d in my career
and then you realize well this was just the total
wrong path for them no you've never seen that no
no again like i i like i know i romanticize
it a little bit but i also think that that
is a super power like i think it's okay that i
romanticize it because that has led to my success
but i truly believe if they have this dream then
they can make it happen and so it's really it
really just comes back down to them having
the desire if you have a desire for a dream
i will help you i believe that you can make
it happen it's as simple as that for me
when did you first hear of abraham hicks
oh gosh years ago i don't remember five
years ago maybe i i went to one of
their live events a couple years ago
yeah maybe five or six years ago and it's all
about um manifestation it's it's law of attraction
you know esther hicks channels an entity called
abraham i know that's very weird if you're
new it might be too for you but um but it's just
information about law of attraction where people
just ask them questions and they answer and it's
no matter what they ask it's very applicable to
anyone's what they're going through anyone's
life so um yeah so i've been listening for
years because it helps me and i like it what are
the big problems that are arising for artists
during covid and how are you helping
them through it i love this question
because i have been humbled with the answer
to this question i have really learned a lot
i have seen proof during kovid that absolutely
anything is possible and to me that is
incredible for i always give these examples sarah
cooper i don't know if you know sarah cooper
she's a comedian a writer she posted
on social media these funny videos
are on tick tock i think and she blew up and
she was already like i think she was already
doing some work but she just blew up during
the pandemic while hollywood is shut down
like things aren't even filming at all
and she ends up getting a netflix special
and she also is invited to do the i think the
opening night monologue on one of the late night
tv shows and she did a phenomenal job i watched it
was so impressed it's a great example of like even
when the industry is shut down opportunities still
exist and to me that has been so humbling because
you know i can fall into the victim mode of
like oh my gosh this is so hard i mean look
you know my business i lost 60 of
my business during the pandemic
but i did pivot and i was like well how else
can i serve people right now how else can i help
people right now instead of just throwing in the
towel right so i think you know the way that i'm
supporting my clients during the pandemic
is a little different now because things
have started up and things are filming i mean
not as much as before but things are filming
but i'm really you know empowering them to believe
that their dreams are still possible during this
time i mean there are other artists that have
you know really blown up and gotten a lot of
attention and opportunity during this time caitlyn
riley is another example her instagram account
blew up she does this like hilarious 60
second videos that people really related to
and really loved and her account blew up i see
she getting like sponsor deals now you know so
it's been humbling it's like erica come on
you teach this that anything is possible and
and so um that's been exciting for me to learn you
know like really anything is possible at any time
there's no wrong time to pursue your dream even
this pandemic i don't think it's the wrong time
and you started your book in february 2020 yeah i
started writing in february yes wow yeah right so
i wrote a book during the pandemic you know yeah
and now you're doing the audiobook yes wow yes so
you're basically saying okay one one part you know
you said you're pivoting so at what point did you
say okay i'm showing up at the computer
today to write this first page of this book
i don't mean to sound annoying but like i never
struggled with that oh okay i just didn't i
because like when i got the i so the idea for
the book wasn't a strategic pivoting move from
the pandemic it was just happened to be like in
december of the previous year of 2019 december
october november december is when i
started to get the nudge to write the book
um and so i was already planning to
do it before the pandemic happened
um and i just i talked about this in the book
but it just felt like i was divinely guided
to write this book and i had to get this
message out and so it it was a challenging
path in terms of like i rewrote the first chapter
100 times you know that it was it was challenging
and finding my voice and how i you know do i want
this book to just be for hollywood or do i want
it to be for everyone and that was an interesting
learning experience figuring that you know solving
that problem and figuring out do i want this
message to be applicable applicable to everyone
and if i do how much hollywood do i include
how much do i exclude so there was you know
challenges in in that aspect but i never really
struggled with like oh my gosh i have to sit down
at the computer today and write this right going
back you said you're a self-starter yes i i just
felt very inspired to do it but like look the
audiobook is taking me forever because because
it's so much work and i'm not really sitting i've
only recorded like a chapter and a half so uh yeah
you